Hello, David. Here we go.
We're live. We're, we're
doing it. Yes, we're doing it.
I'm nervous. I'm nervous. Don't be, I
enjoy your show. I really do. Thank you.
It's a pleasure to watch you. You're very
smart guy, man. You, and like I said,
we were just talking about it.
You're very reasonable in this world.
I think there's so much of this,
the youtube political world,
the youtube commentary world where people
are so fucking toxic, you know, there's,
there's so much negativity, there's so
much what they called dunking on people.
There's so much dunking and you do a
little Dunkin. Some of it's warranted.
It is warranted. Yes. But I don't
know if it's beneficial, uh, to the,
to the people doing the dunking.
Yes. Or even to the cause.
I think it is temporarily,
but sometimes it's good because it showed
that mocks people's positions and it
makes people realize, yeah,
that is a ridiculous position.
So if you're on the fence or if you're
not really quite sure how you feel about
things and you see someone get mocked
for ridiculous position that maybe you
even shared for a little bit.
Right.
Maybe maybe haven't explored it deeply
and you see someone who has explored that
deeply sort of expose all the flaws
in this line of thinking it's good.
But my thing when I interview a lot of
people on the right and a lot of people
on the left and I just hate
all this conflict that I,
I'd say the unnecessary
conflict I think is when you,
when you watch television today and
you see Antifa fighting with the,
you know,
Trump supporters and all this,
all this weird conflict.
I don't,
I don't necessarily think that
most of it is, is necessary.
Necessary. Well I think the devil's in
the details. Yeah. So like as an example,
if you want to bring together,
I don't know,
people who are on opera opposite
opposite sides of the climate debate for
example. Good luck, I'm sure. Right? Well,
why is part part of that you could argue
is if one side just does not accept
science, how can you really
bring those people together?
It doesn't mean you need physical
conflict to resolve it. In fact,
I completely agree with you. The physical
conflict is totally counter productive,
but at a certain point on some issues,
I understand why there's
like an intractability to
the debate where it seems
completely impossible to move forward
because whichever side you're on,
I would argue that I'm on the right
side of these issues and others would
disagree.
When you're far apart in a way that you
can't even agree as to like what the
starting point facts are about
the conversation. How do you even,
how do you start? I have some ideas as to
how I try to do it, but it's very tough.
It is very tough.
I just don't think dunking on people
always like constantly shitting on people
is necessarily the way.
Yeah,
and I think it's important to distinguish
between just straight up ad hominems
where someone is wrong and bad,
uh,
because I think they're a bad person
or they're an idiot or whatever to
recognizing when somebody is a
participant in bad faith in a conversation
to when someone has maybe fallen prey to
audience capture or whatever else might
be kind of influencing what,
what and how they're doing.
I think that those
criticisms are legitimate,
but you got to stay away from just
ad Hominem. Yes, yes, I agree.
And I think that it's just so
common today. It's, it's, it's,
it's also extremely attractive.
The, the Youtube Algorithm,
uh, you know, as far as,
um, comments go, I mean,
it actually kind of encourages it
and so does Facebook. So it does,
you know, anytime there's a social
media platform that is add dependent,
one of the best ways to get people to
engage is to have something they disagree
with so they can get angry.
Yes.
Until it becomes no longer brand safe
according to whoever's running the
platform. Right. I mean,
you go back to April,
2017 where I woke up and saw that my
youtube channel made 19 cents the previous
day. And I text Kyle Kalinsky and I
say, I think there's like a glitch.
Is it like it says I made 19
cents? And he says, he says,
I made 35 cents or something like
that. Uh, something's going on.
And it was the beginning of like an
apocalypse 1.0 and that was a rough three
week period. And uh, so, so you know,
encourage the debate and the battle of
ideas so to speak in all of this stuff
until advertisers get worried
and they say, oh, you know,
our ads are showing up on stuff that's
a little bit touch and go for us.
That's a weird one to me because um,
I,
youtube has always been a
secondary thought for me.
The first thought was the audio version
of the podcast and in fact when we were
uploading it to youtube at first I
was like, why are we even doing this?
I guess why not?
Some people probably want to watch it
and then somewhere along the line it
became at least close to as
big as the audio version of it.
And then maybe even more significant
because one of the things that the youtube
version has is the comment section,
which is often the fucking dumpster fire,
but it at least there is some sort of
like a community engagement aspect of it
that doesn't really exist in iTunes.
Like an iTunes, it's sort of,
it's in a vacuum. Right? Sure. Um,
but when the ad pocalypse thing
happened, I was like, hmm,
what was going on here? Like
wasn't, it wasn't my primary focus,
so it wasn't terrifying.
But people that only did
youtube and people that relied
on that for their living,
I mean it was, it's a huge blow.
It was huge. And at the time,
I'm trying to think back,
I think maybe like around 30% of my entire
shows revenue was coming from youtube
at the time. So it was not everything, but
it was still significant. Right. I mean,
I've staff and overhead and all
of that stuff, so just overnight,
30% going away is huge.
And that's why I've tried to move
to the model of telling my audience,
you can skip all of this stuff.
You know, even, uh, uh, some
of these other, you know,
super chats and all of this other stuff.
Like we run a membership
program on my website,
I control a hundred percent of it. So
it's not a patriot and you are on Patrion,
but it's not big for us.
The way I think about it is as long as,
I mean, listen, yeah, there's, you know,
marijuana companies that are having
trouble even processing payments.
But assuming like stripe and paypal,
don't say you can't even accept
payments anymore. David Pakman,
I control the entire process
on my website. So when
people pay their six bucks,
all but 2.9% gets to me.
And when ad apocalypse happened,
I saw it as a maybe blessing in disguise
and that I can now explain to the
audience, here's the problem with
these algorithms. Here's the problem.
When it goes from,
I am fighting white supremacist
content to an algorithm,
can't distinguish between that and
white supremacists content. Right?
That's bad for me. Right. When
I interviewed Richard Spencer,
I obviously don't agree
with Richard Spencer. Uh,
but can an algorithm figure
out that there's a difference
between an interview I
do with Richard Spencer and white
nationalist propaganda? I don't know.
But we can kind of get around all of
that if you just go directly to me.
And that's why my focus has been growing
that those direct members you interview
Richard Spencer. Yeah. Did you
get shit for that? Yes. Yeah.
That's a weird one. Right.
And you know, um, I'm sure
you're aware of that, uh, that,
what is it called,
data and society that can,
whether there was a woman who
made a bunch of connections,
like Joe Rogan knows David Packman
and Joe Rogan also knows Alex Jones.
Alex Jones wants to be friends with
David Pakman. Like the math sort of,
it was like one of those
minds and it was really weird.
It's like guilt by association.
I saw a couple of them.
There was like an initial one
which made be thinking of,
then there was a map of like the youtube
sphere specifically left middle and
right or something like that.
Yeah.
And this idea that everyone's like on a
part of a grand conspiracy to help each
other out and push right ideology.
Even though you know a lot of people
that were labeled as right. Art, right?
Like who like me, Oh,
I'm not writing at all.
My sense is you're politics
are pretty left on most stuff.
Um, although I don't, I mean,
I don't know you personally
beyond just seeing your shows. Um,
but maybe the critique is based on,
because I think that those maps were
based on what is the youtube algorithm
suggesting. And so that may not be
in line with your personal politics.
Maybe what we're talking about,
like if you're interested in conflict
and if you're trying to get engagement,
that's the way to do it.
Like in a few youtube out
youtube algorithm is constantly
suggesting people like
Ben Shapiro, right? Gavin
McInnes or whatever.
And those videos come up over
and over again. Sure. And I mean,
so a lot of those people's
channels do really well on youtube.
So if you interview someone
who has a channel themselves,
there's a very good
chance that the algorithm,
if they're watching your interview
with that person, will say, well,
here's a lot of their stuff.
And then once you click there,
the algorithm very quickly
starts to build a picture of,
of every individual user.
If you watch your interview with Ben
Shapiro and then it takes you to a daily
wire video, then it takes you to like the
daily wire, second string or guy, right.
And then you're off. Who knows where,
right. It's all machine learning. Right?
I mean that's one of the most
part. Yeah, that's a, it is.
It's a troubling aspect of that thing
that they do where they suggest the next
videos, which didn't use to be a thing.
It used to be you would go to youtube,
you would watch a video, right? And then
you would go find another video. Right.
They didn't suggest anything.
And then somewhere along the line,
I don't remember what year it was,
but this started happening and then they
started auto playing the next video.
Auto play.
Yeah.
I think there was some kind of
recommendation thing very early on,
but initially it might have
been restricted to just
other videos from the same
channel you're watching probably,
and at a certain point it started
to recommend other things.
And I don't know if you look at your
analytics and see what percentage of your
views are coming from that
recommendations feed from other stuff.
Um, but it's significant for a
lot of youtube channels. The,
the tagging your videos and getting the
right metadata on them in order to bring
an audience is an important thing.
So it's a double edged sword in some
sentence it sounds, sounds like,
but to get back to what you were
saying about so rich labeled you owe is
Richards. Okay. Yeah, I was going to
say it. They labeled you as right,
but you're not right. Do what other
ones? It's disingenuous. I mean,
I've said it over and over and over again.
I've never voted for a
Republican in my life.
I've voted independent for Gary Johnson
just because he did my podcast. Okay.
I wasn't happy with Clinton and I
wasn't happy with Trump. I was like,
this is gross. I'm just going to
vote for Gary Johnson. I mean,
I didn't think he was going to win.
You know,
he had almost no chance when he didn't
know what Aleppo was. Right. I was like,
that was his, he was his
scream. You know, like, uh,
what's his face from New Hampshire?
Howard Dean. Howard Dean. Yeah.
Well voting in California also.
I S I assume you've,
I'm sure it wasn't going to Joe. Yeah. Um,
but people conveniently,
we'll just as,
or they'll say that like
you're a Trojan horse.
They like a pretend left wing person
who's really just pushing right wing
ideologies. I'm like,
well which one? Which,
which right wing ideologies that gay
marriage is it, what is it? I put,
I'm on the left on everything except
maybe a second amendment right.
I think the criticism that um,
could be levied if one wanted to make it
into a criticism would be if you engage
with right wing ideas and that
you don't agree with, right.
Like I take you at your face,
you know,
at face value that you don't agree with
a lot of the stuff that you're right.
When guests say one could
make the argument that by
not challenging those ideas,
it's implicitly lending
them more credibility than
maybe you think they should
have. That's interesting because
what I try to do with people, um,
unless something, say someone saying
something egregious, I try to let
them talk.
I want to know how they feel.
I want to know what
their thought processes.
And so instead of just challenging on it
on everything, I want them to elaborate.
Right.
And I feel like by doing that,
I get a sense of how they've come to
that conclusion and whether it's logical,
right? Whether it's a,
when they're, they've,
they've actually used their thoughts and
they've really calculated and thought,
this is the position I take. And this is
why. And I, a lot of people don't know,
there's a lot of, a lot of the times we
challenged people in their positions,
you find out like they don't really know
what the fuck they're talking about and
that the best way to find that out as the,
let them talk like Candace
Owens on climate change,
right? That was, I mean, there's
the Socratic method of questioning,
which is why do you think that? And how
do you know that that's true? Et Cetera,
et cetera. And sort of some other
questions that come from it. Uh,
which I do as well. Um, I
mean I think, I don't know to,
to tie it to the Richard
Spencer interview that I did,
some of the criticism I received after
was from people on the left. I mean,
the people,
I would assume it was most of the people
on the low for doing the interview. Yes.
Or for what I said in the interview
for what I'm doing it. Okay. Yeah.
For doing the interview at all.
The criticism was more from the left
for what I said in the interview.
The criticism was more from the right,
from people who just agreed
with Richard Spencer,
like what things did they agree with
that it is inevitable that people with
different ethnic or religious backgrounds
simply will not be able to coexist
together peacefully and we're better
off trying to figure out how can we
separate people based on their
membership in ethnic or religious groups.
Separatism.
I mean literally separatism.
That's sad.
That's a sad thought that you just can't
get along with people that do other
things that are interested,
interested in other things that come
from other places that have different
religions that have different
points of view. Like why,
uh, the Oh, well they, they
have a series of, uh, you know,
decades of what they call
scholarship supporting their view.
But for the context of my interview,
I made it abundantly clear that I didn't
agree with that stuff. Right. Yeah.
And my view is,
and everybody can have a different
view about how they do interviews.
My view is if I just allow the,
what I consider to be disgusting views
to be spread out, right. You know,
like a spray bottle to spray them
everywhere, not do anything else. Uh,
I can't say that I'm doing
something that I think is valuable.
I don't feel like it's
valuable. So my, my approach is,
are the ideas known enough
to be worth refuting?
That's number one.
If it's some weird conspiracy theory that
has not even any following whatsoever,
I'm probably not going to choose to even
entertain it because it's irrelevant in,
in sort of always.
So my first question is it was Richard
Spencer relevant at the time outright was
rising, this guy was considered by many
of the sort of creator of the outright,
he was growing a following in the
context of the Trump candidacy,
the time or maybe administration.
I don't remember when exactly it was,
it was I think 2016 or,
I'm trying to remember when it was.
I don't remember when I first heard
his name. Yeah. But how did he become,
how did he come to prominence?
I don't know the sequence,
but I think he had a wet,
an alt right website that had
articles of some kind and then,
um, he, that website became
more known and the fucking term,
so talk the alt right,
you know,
all left the centrist,
like all these,
all these different labels or talk
about issues. I agree with you there.
So clunky. But, so, you know, first
thing was I did want to interview him,
but if I had felt that I
wouldn't be prepared to make
it abundantly clear that I
don't agree with the guy.
And I think his ideas are terrible.
I wouldn't have done the interview yet.
So the problem I had with the critiques
from the left of me doing that,
some who said, the last thing we need
to be doing is giving this guy a voice.
That's often how they say it,
or a platform.
My response was this guy's getting
interviewed in lots of other places that
aren't even challenging him.
Right.
I'm at least making an attempt here to
get something in the record that there
are arguments against these ideas.
These are bad ideas.
And I don't want to be part of the
diffusion of just the ideas themselves.
I'm gonna have to,
I'm going to be pushing back.
I'm going to have to watch that
note. Now. When you did do that,
like what was his response
was during the interview,
what was his response to your push back?
Uh, I mean he had answers, you know, he's,
he's, he was well prepared.
I don't know if they're,
they were unique or new
arguments that I was making. Um,
but there was no argument to be made
that I was letting him just parrot white
nationalists talking points on a post,
which I wouldn't,
I just wouldn't feel good about that.
It's not how I do interviews. Yeah.
And then the left was upset that you're
giving him air quotes, a platform,
very small portion of the left. I just
want to be super clear. Let's go left.
I mean my audience is very left. Almost
everybody understood what I was doing.
10 years ago I was interviewing
the Westboro Baptist church.
Most people understood what I was doing.
They were more prominent at the time,
but there was this sliver of the left
that just didn't want the conversation to
take place. And I always struggle
with this because as you can see,
I have no problem criticizing
that sliver of the left.
My concern is getting like overly wrapped
up to criticisms of the left that are
only held by these like niche
slices. Yes. And that's why,
um,
I try to avoid going further than
necessary into those criticisms.
Like I think there are more serious
critiques of the left to be made, um,
beyond anti speech or want
to limit speech or whatever.
I mean that's, that's a pretty
big issue. Well, I don't,
I don't actually agree that it exists
on a significant portion of the left.
Like I think a bigger issue,
for example,
like if you said what is like a serious
issue that the left needs to contend
with right now?
I would say a more serious issue
is if you look at the progressive
accomplishments of the early 20th century,
for example,
like 19 five to 1925 and the new deal
accomplishments that the left had in the
time of Fdr,
what was different,
I think then than the left now is that
you didn't have to be completely in line
with a specific set of policies or ideas.
And I worry that now there's a little bit,
um,
of the left maybe having this idea that
if you're not in line on all of these
issues, whatever the
checklist is, so to speak,
you're not really worthy of being a
participant in what is clearly a leftward
move in sort of the average
Americans political orientation.
I don't want to see that prevent progress.
Right? Yeah. That's the, that's the
hard tribalism, right? That's worth the,
the line gets drawn. You're with us or
against us. And there's one way to think
there is,
there is a lot of that.
I mean I saw it with healthcare
recently with healthcare.
I don't think that you can make any
serious case from the left that healthcare
is fine and the for profit employer
connected system that we have is working.
Like I, I don't think there's any
progressive case to be made for that.
Where people will differ is what about
Medicare for all versus some other system
system that looks more like Canada's
or the UK or Germany or whatever.
And I've already started to
see like when I say on my show,
I'm kind of agnostic on this,
like the system we have as a disaster,
we need a system that will
get coverage to everybody.
The the numbers can be made to work any
number of different ways we've looked at
it,
but 80% of people on Medicare I believe
it is have some additional coverage.
They either are still working part time
or full time and get coverage that way
or they're poor enough to be on Medicaid.
The point is medicare for all
doesn't solve every issue.
It's way better than what we have, but
here's like a dozen other possibilities.
Looking at other countries,
there is a portion of the left that
doesn't like that because I'm saying I'm
against Medicare for all.
I'm not saying that.
What I'm saying is there are a number
of different ways to improve upon the
system.
We have all of which sever
this relationship between
usually your employer and
these for profit insurance companies.
Y'All yet we'd be open to them. I really
don't understand private citizens that
don't want easy access to quality health
care for everybody. That confuses
the shit out of me. Like,
have you ever been hurt?
Have you ever been sick? Have
you ever been broke? Right?
Do you want to be broke and have no
access to healthcare? No one does.
No one wants anybody to care about to
not have access to health care of all the
things that we concentrate
on this country,
there's two things that drive me
fucking crazy that people just dismiss
education and healthcare. The idea
that you have to like my buddy Greg,
Greg Fitzsimmons,
he's sending his kid off to school.
How much did he say that it was?
65 or $65,000 a year for both of his kids,
for each of his kid. So you know,
he's got two kids that that's,
that hurts my head.
Even about spending
$130,000 a year just on,
if you're a regular person with a
regular job, how the fuck do you do that?
Impossible. It's impossible.
It's so much fucking money.
And then that's not
even paying for housing.
And Food and transportation and books
and everything else that you're going to
need to.
And to make it more difficult for young
people to succeed is one of the worst
ways to make a stronger country.
If you want to see a strong country,
you want educated people that
get to pursue their dreams.
And the idea that we are so willing
to spend so much money on these costly
regime change wars and flying troops
overseas to these places that they don't
want to go. No one, no
one wants it to happen.
And it's trillions of dollars
and people are fine with that.
But you talk to them about some sort of
socialize education system and people
freak out and think you want
to turn us into Communist.
Well I think what is really important
to understand is that the facts you just
laid out don't matter to people who
see this as an issue of what do people
deserve?
What do they deserve?
So if you say to a fiscal conservative,
you know,
if you consider the amount that the
employee pays for premiums plus the
employer, plus your copays, a
plus Co insurance, right? You,
you put it all together into some
amount and you explain to them.
There's lots of great analyses that
have been done which tell us that with
roughly the same amount of money,
maybe small payroll tax in addition
with roughly that same amount,
it all could be done with a single
payer system that covers everybody.
It's the same.
You're taking all of these individual
risk pools where you have different
for-profit insurers and then you have
systems for people that don't have enough
money. Medicaid, you have systems
for people that are over 65 medicare.
You put it all together,
you spread the risk far wider.
The employer no longer has to
pay their part of the premium.
The employee no longer pays part of
their premium to the for profit insurance
company. The numbers work. They're still
not going to say, you know what, that?
That sounds great. It's actually
pretty fiscally conservative.
Let's do it because at some point there
is a portion of the right that just
doesn't think people have earned
healthcare. They just haven't earned it.
They have education or
education. Yeah, that's right.
And it's very hard to change people's
minds when that's their view.
I think it's might be George Lake off
who I believe calls it strict father
morality,
which is like how would a really strict
father treat a child who comes to them
and says, Hey, you know what? I figured
out a way that we can all have healthcare.
The strict father, even if the
numbers make sense, would say,
I'm going to teach you a lesson.
You haven't earned that health care
either because you don't work or you don't
make enough money or you're on disability,
whatever the case may be.
How do you convince someone
to change their mind when
that's the world worldview?
Yeah. How do you, when it's a,
an ideologically based decision and
the you're on team our or team l,
you know what, which uh, which group of
ideas do you adopt? Right. Ah,
in the UK system sucks.
Need you talk to people that get
health care over in the UK it's socks,
but at least they have a system.
It's just not the same quality
health care that you get in America.
Same with my friends in Canada.
I have friends in Canada that have come
down here to get surgery because they
find better doctors over here because
the Paul was going to Canada to get his,
um, uh, operation. That was, why
was that? Why did he do that?
The best places in Canada, the best place
for Hernias for that type of hernia,
I believe. Yeah. Hmm. I
mean, here's the thing,
even in saying the UK system and the
Canadian system, neither one is that good,
right? Those two systems are
totally different, right?
So if I fucked the whole socialized
medicine, they are both, well, yes,
in some sense. I mean, the Canadian system
is administered at the province level.
So the province is sort
of like the market.
Instead of having all these submarkets
attached to individual for-profit
insurers at the provincial level,
uh, that's how it's organized.
The UK has a, the national health
service where they're actually,
they don't actually run
the healthcare facilities,
but they're the ones who
are contracting them.
So it's sort of like the
health care facility still, uh,
isn't own entity.
It's not that you're going
and the government is the
employer of the doctors so
to speak, but they're contracting
with the health care facilities.
But the point I want to make is that
there are criticisms of all of these
systems,
but there are different ones.
So when we say the British and Canadian
systems aren't that good, right,
let's figure out in what
ways each is not that good.
Because there are different ways, whether
you're talking about health outcomes,
early detection, cost
per treatment, whatever.
You really have to drill down and figure
out in what way are we saying it's not
as good. Yeah. What I'm saying is
that there is no perfect system.
There is no perfect systems are right,
but I believe that most of the best
doctors in terms of like North America at
least,
or in the United States,
I'm sure there's probably some very good
doctors in Canada that do specialize
medicine, but I think really good
doctors are incentivized by profit.
I really do.
I think there is some motivation for
if you spend so much money for medical
school and you,
you bust your ass,
you want to make a lot of money and some
of the best doctors earn a really good
living, then I think, I
think limiting their, uh,
their ability to earn that money won't
incentivize people to be excellent.
So a couple of different things.
I mean, number one, to be clear,
we're just now starting to get into a
little bit of broader economic philosophy.
Like I'm a capitalist, I'm, I'm for
social democracy, which is a mixed system.
That's a capitalist system that
says we're going to invest, uh,
tax revenue in a particular way to make
sure that no one falls below a certain
level. So I, my, my, just
to contextualize that,
my point of view is not from one
of becoming a socialist country.
So I think we share those
views. I think. So. Um,
a lot of doctors will say
that even though on sort of,
on paper,
in a socialized
medicine system, they might make less
for a particular procedure, for example,
or something like that.
A lot of them are still in favor of those
systems because it would drastically
reduce their overhead.
So there's all of this apparatus that
includes medical billing and coding both
on the insurer end and at the healthcare
provider and the hospital and the
insurance company both are battling over
what is it that was done right and what
are the codes that apply here and how,
what are our reimbursement rates?
There's fraud when it comes to that.
Um,
and that requires an apparatus
for investigating and
adjudicating that that adds
more and more cost.
So I don't think it says easy.
I don't think it's as obvious that under
those systems, at the end of the day,
a doctor that owns a PCP,
a group for example,
or an orthopedic clinic or
whatever the case may be,
I don't know that it's that clear that
they end up taking home less money. Hm.
That's interesting. I'd wonder if in
practice that would play out that way.
I mean,
maybe I'm talking about just like high
end orthopedic surgeons that do knee
surgeries for athletes and
things along those lines.
They often would be outside of whatever
insurance apparatus we were talking
about anyway. A lot of those folks are
often being paid out of pocket anyway.
So it's less in belief,
some at least some.
So for the average person's experience,
I think it's less relevant.
Yeah. Um, then there's also liability
insurance, which is extremely expensive.
That's a giant issue with, with
doctors. It's a huge expense.
It is. Yeah. I mean I
think it is necessary. Uh,
there's a question as to whether
it's organized in the best way.
I know less about that component than
some of the other ones, you know? Um,
th th th the education and healthcare,
those are the two things that I think we
can both agree we need to invest money
on and we need to figure out some way
to make that more accessible. Yes. Yes.
And I don't understand
people that don't think that.
And if that's what that is the
strict father mentality, that just,
the only thing that it makes sense to
me is that you don't want people who are
kind of half ass in college
did that can just get in.
I think that that comes up a lot. Yeah.
And you hear about so called Free College,
which isn't free. It's where we're saying
we're paying for it through taxation.
Really important to point that out.
It's, it's just not for everybody.
And that's okay. I mean, I think that
that, that sometimes gets lost. Yes,
yes. There are more and more jobs
that require college degrees.
Even though you could make the case,
maybe the college degree
is not actually necessary,
but it's a way to sort of thin the herd
of applicants in order to just make
hiring, uh, you know,
more, more practical. Um,
but I do think that it's okay to say
that college isn't for everybody,
but the same ideas that apply
to so called free college,
meaning college paid for through
education could apply to trade school.
They could apply to retraining programs.
There's a whole bunch of other ways that
it could be done. Yeah, no, I agree. Yeah.
I just,
the
college is not for everyone.
Thing is more true now than ever before,
particularly with certain
technology studies.
You're learning things during your four
years at a university that are just
going to be completely outdated by
the time you graduated in what kind of
program? For example, Jamie, what he
did with audio engineering. Oh I see.
You went to school for audio engineering.
By the time he got out it was all useless,
but that was not a four year bachelors
program. Right. It is now. Oh it is now.
Okay. When I went there, it
wasn't available for that.
But since then they have made that
available and that's also in the time that
youtube has made basically
education free for a lot of people.
Sure.
So I mean I think with that,
the issue is in my mind that when you
consider the cost relative to the earnings
potential,
as you pointed out,
when you're talking about $68,000
a year or you know, whatever it is,
guest taught at Boston college and I
think it was like 64,000 or something like
that. Um, depending on what
field you're going into, it's,
it's almost impossible to
pay that off ever. So some,
at some point something needs to change.
And this kind of gets us into the
technological automate automation and
unemployment stuff of what happens as
computers and technology start to replace
jobs. And that's where I think there's a
pretty clear line between a free market
capitalist, a Social Democrat
like myself and actual socialism.
Like what should happen with the gains
that come from those technological
advancements. But as far as the
education piece is concerned,
so it's completely
unsustainable the way it is.
No,
I knew about you before this happened,
but then I really kind of got on board
with you when someone was trying to get
you fired from Boston University. And I
remember some college, Boston College,
sorry. And I tweeted it and I was
like, right, like what? What is this?
This is craziness.
So it's a woman named [inaudible],
Amy Siskind, who, I don't
know. Other than that incident
where you had a disagreement about
something, it wasn't, it wasn't toxic.
It wasn't hostile, I would
think. Said I didn't lose that.
Explain what you said and what she,
what she had said that you disagree with.
So we may be able to
even find the tweet,
but she tweeted something that just being,
um,
that she would not be supporting any
candidate in 2020 who's white or male.
I think that that was the gist of it. And
I responded, I'm going from memory here.
The gist was something like,
isn't that the definition of racism?
You're sort of preemptively excluding
someone from consideration on the basis of
race and in that case, gender, if it was
white and there it is right there. Uh,
yeah.
There's a court,
I will not support white male candidates
in the den primary unless you slept
through midterms.
Women were our most successful candidate,
biggest dem vote getters in history.
Obama,
oh eight Hillary 16 white male
is not where our party is at.
Entities are at least safe
option in 2020. Right. So I said,
isn't something not progressive
about preemptively dismissing a
candidate based on their race and gender?
I feel like there's a word to
describe that as a progressive.
I won't be jumping on board. Yeah.
So you can explode basically.
Didn't even say it's racist,
right? You said there's a
word to describe that. Yeah,
and that's a very polite way
of disagreeing with someone.
I thought it was polite and she
tried to get you fired. Yeah,
she contacted as far as I
know, so. Okay. I don't,
I'm going by what she said.
She said she contacted Boston college
and told them not to allow me to teach
there. That's insane. And Boston
College, since I've just an adjunct,
I'm not on staff when I'm not teaching,
like during the three months of the
semester I'm employed there and the other
nine months I'm not.
So I think Boston College said he's not
currently employed here and I think that
that's basically as far as it went.
But I did talk to some other faculty
there who were aware of the thing that was
going on.
That's a crazy thing to do just to think.
So it's a nasty mean thing to do to like
what someone can't disagree with you.
And it's a very good point.
I think she probably got upset because
you made a very good point and tweets
started coming her way
and a lot of people,
they read those fucking comments and
people get toxic in those comments. Yeah.
Random strange people that you don't
know and then you're forced to, you know,
look at their opinions and their
criticisms and their insults.
That incident started me down the path
of drastically limiting my social media
use. Good for you. Yeah, I mean that,
that was the beginning and then it became,
I mean,
you know this way more than I do because
I think on all platforms you have
roughly 10 times the following that I do,
no matter what you do post or whatever,
if you look at what the feedback is,
it's extraordinarily toxic and
horrible negative stuff that is only a
distraction to what I'm trying to do.
And most of it probably isn't,
but I hadn't evolved on yesterday
number all Brown Mckenna. Yeah.
And one of the things that he
brought up this so, so huge,
it's so true is that you
can have 10 positive things,
but that one negative will outweigh
the 10 positives in your mind. You,
me and your mom. Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely.
Especially if you're a person who's
self critical or a self, uh, objective,
you're analyzing your behavior.
Was that good? Was that bad? Right?
Then you read that one bad
comment. Fuck, are they right?
You don't read all the people
that say you're great. Oh
brilliant. Loved it. Yeah.
Fuck you. Loser. Oh, absolutely.
I mean when I announced I was
going to be doing your show,
if you look at what the comments were,
almost all this is awesome.
Great Wing voice talking to
Joe Rogan. Go get him. David.
This is such a great opportunity. I can't
wait to watch you face plant. Oh Geez.
And that's the one where I'm
like, man, are they right?
Like I'm not going to money in
a face plant. So I don't know.
I'm just trying to limit the
amount that I'm on social media.
One thing I am doing though because I
mean my show is in part as successful as
it is because of social media.
So it, I can't that right.
You don't have to engage.
I don't have to engage.
And I also can just say,
I will check our networks in the morning,
then I'll spend the whole day,
I'll do my show,
I'll do what I need to do and then
before I sign off for the evening,
I'll check it [inaudible] right.
Because what if you read the worst shit
right before you eat dinner and go to
bed? Well know it'll be like 5:00
PM so you'll have five hours,
30 hours to cool off it and
it's way better. And weekends,
I'm almost, I mean, uh,
people are like, David, you're
still treating on the weekends.
A lot of those are like prescheduled
tweets where I'll just sit and schedule
some stuff and I am trying to stay off
it and it's been really great. I mean,
it's been a fantastic, looked
at our phones yesterday. Uh,
we did a sober October podcast
with my four friends. Yep.
We looked at our phones to look at phone
usage and I use my iPhone four hours a
day on my phone for hours a day
and like, fuck. That's a lot.
What app did you use to measure it? It's
something on your iPhone. Oh, okay. Yeah.
You have a android. I'm sure they
have a similar thing. Yeah. Yeah.
Four hours of screen time. I'm
like, Ooh, that's not good.
They're adding that to the a computer too,
so it's going to combine.
You'll know how much you're
looking at all screens soon. Yeah.
What if you're writing? Well, I was
going to count that kind of sure.
Work staring at the screen.
That's how it worked. Pitch. Hey,
that's what the argument you guys are
making for the phone just as birth.
Sorry man. Yeah. Well Burt's arguments
not good because he doesn't even write.
That's ridiculous.
One thing I did that actually is useful
is I used to have my social apps on the
home screen and cal Newport
and some others have said got,
you've got to get rid of those.
He actually advocates getting rid of the
apps all together so that you have to
go on a computer and choose to
go to facebook.com or Twitter.
I haven't gotten there yet,
but even just removing them from the
home screen makes me significantly less
likely to even pull them up.
It's two clicks to swipe up and
scroll over to the APP. Right.
But even just getting them
off the homescreen keeps me
off of them significantly.
That's smart. That makes sense. Yeah.
I need a certain amount of access to
those things with my business. Right.
Scheduling shows and things
along those lines, but yeah,
it's not good for you.
I mean,
I think one of the biggest realizations
is that people don't really miss you
that much. They don't hear
from you for a couple of days.
Like that's one of the things where
the idea of needing constant engagement
comes from sort of like a
slightly narcissistic point
of view where like people
are going to notice if I don't tweet
for from Thursday night until Monday
morning or do anything. Right.
Right, right, right. They
really don't. They don't.
They don't. There's a lot of other
people to pay attention. Yes, there are.
There are a few people
that tweet on you that,
that are kind of crazy and that want to
hear from you all day long. Yeah. Yeah.
But they'll get used to it. They'll
get used to you. They will vanishing.
And I don't know, I mean, cal
Newport has, have you had him on,
he wrote deep work and then more recently
he wrote digital minimalism and he
goes into detail about just the effect
of, uh, uh, write it down on my phone,
but it feels sacrilegious to put that as
a take it out right now. Yeah. I mean,
he goes into detail this stuff
and just about, you know,
we need more uninterrupted periods of
concentration for what is the book called
again?
Deep Work and then digital minimalism.
And they're both, I interviewed
him recently. Really just
solid, very solid stuff.
Awesome. Yeah. Um, what were
we just about to get into? Oh,
so when he says this woman,
Amy Siskind,
did you reach out to her when she did
that? And privately? Yeah. No, no.
Did you read a job publicly?
Uh,
well you did publicly declare that you
try to get you fired, right? Yes, I did.
Did she respond? I don't know cause
she blocked me. Oh God dammit.
She blocked you over that. Yeah. Geez us.
That is so sensitive.
And what,
what is Twitter for? Right?
Is it just to fall in line?
Is it just to agree with
everything someone says with
no questioning whatsoever.
What's extra interesting about
it is she blocked me on Twitter,
but then I treat my Facebook
profile basically as public.
So I post stuff on there. It's the same
whether you're friends with me or not.
And I had posted something
totally innocuous about,
I was at a restaurant or
drinking an espresso on it.
I don't even know what it was.
She showed up there and commented that
she had called Boston college and told
them not to, you know, not to
hire me or to fire me or whatever.
Honestly hosts about you
having an espresso. It was
just a personal posts. Right.
But the point she determined that the
exchange was worthy of blocking me on
Twitter.
But then she came to my
personal Facebook page and said,
I'm calling Boston college
and telling them to fire you.
There's a word for that.
God, that's really a few. This is a
gang, but there's a big one. Yeah,
this is a four letter one that I just
don't understand why someone would want to
do that to someone. Why? Why
can't you disagree? Why can't you,
and she's just upset that you pointed
out a glaring problem with what she was
saying. Yeah, I apparently, and
you know the thing is I don't, I,
the way I operate, I don't think even
necessarily that she's a bad person.
I just assumed that she has, you
know, some emotional thing going on.
She could have had a terrible
date as far as I know,
someone near and dear to
her died that day. I am.
If someone near and dear to me died,
I wouldn't go.
Wouldn't be necessarily be on Twitter
or your Facebook post about you drinking
an espresso fair, fair tote.
People. I've tried to get you fired.
But my approach is I just,
I really do assume most people are
pretty good people and even when we have
disagreements,
I tend to give the benefit of the doubt
that if we could only talk the way we
were doing, we could figure out 95% of
the disagreement. Maybe not all of it.
Right. But most of it. So I don't
pick Roger. I mean, yeah, I don't, I,
she behaved in a way I wouldn't behave,
but who knows what she had going on.
You know? I mean it's, yeah. Well it
didn't get you fired so it's not that bad.
But if it did that would have horrible,
it would have been a different situation.
Would have been probably a good publicity.
Yeah. I probably would. Helps you.
I think so. You got excited
about that. It's funny,
the reason I'm thinking back actually to
a conversation I had at the time where
someone said to me, uh,
if you do get fired,
it's the best possible thing that'll
happen. Right. It would just be fantastic.
And it didn't, cause I wasn't
actually employed there at the time.
That's the irony of it.
Well, this is the thing,
the the falling in line,
the no room for deviation from
the ideology. Sure. This is a,
this is a giant issue that I have
with both, both parties. It's,
and I think that's one of the reasons
why people were in these parties to begin
with.
I don't necessarily think that people
have clearly thought out every single
aspect of whatever part
of they align with.
I think they fall in line and they adopt
a predetermined pattern or behavior
that seems to be attractive at the time
and then they fall in line with whatever
that party is saying. I think that
is a giant percentage of people.
When someone deviates from that,
like you did someone who is also clearly
a progressive and clearly a left wing
person and you're criticizing
something and very,
very politely and that,
that she just goes haywire over that.
That's the thing,
right?
It's like are you responsible for the
people who also comment on your post and
this is,
this is where we're getting to this like
vox thing that's happening with Steven
Crowder right now. Right. Are
you responsible for the reaction?
To what you post because if you look
at what Steven Crowder said to that,
if we don't,
people don't know the story.
Steven Crowder got into it with this
guy who is a writer for Vox who,
uh, is he's gay. His
Twitter handle is gay Wank,
right? Told us Mazda. Yeah. So it's
not that he's hiding that. He's gay,
talks about it all the time.
He's kind of a feminine.
And Steven Crowder mock that and he
mocked that in these videos where he was
criticizing Carlos,
his position on Antifa is
specifically what I saw.
And in doing that, he called him, uh,
this queer Mexican, this like, and
he's doing it in a ribbing way.
He's doing it in a joking way.
And then Carlos Mazda posts all these
horrible tweets that came his way.
And apparently he got docs. So people got
his phone and they were saying debates,
Steven Crowder, who was getting all
these text messages in and all this,
a hateful stuff that was coming his way.
So the question is,
who is responsible for that hateful stuff?
If Steven Crowder calls
him queer is what is queer.
Okay. Is Lbgtq. What do we do there?
What do we do if the queue is,
is he is,
is it okay to call someone
gay who identifies as gay?
If he calls him the gay little
Mexican, is that, is that bad?
Like what is,
how bad is like what is that?
You know what I'm saying? But so do you
feel what I'm saying here? It's like,
do I know where you're getting at? Let's
zoom out a little bit and then we'll,
we'll get into this man.
Where do you even start with this?
Because there's a lot to unpack here,
right?
If we will analyze the specifics
in a second maybe. But first,
if you look at the policy,
the terms of service of Youtube,
there's a verge article from
yesterday before, a few days ago,
earlier this week before youtube had
made the decision to demonetize Steven
Crowder.
Well,
they made the decision to not act initial
say that it didn't violate the terms
of services.
And then today as I got in here,
Jamie informed me that they made
a decision to demon. That's right.
So in the article where they
made the decision not to act,
they actually put what Youtube [inaudible]
terms of service are with regard to
bullying and harassment. My reading
of it, and we could go through them.
If we could pull them up, we could go
through it line by line if we wanted.
My reading was that the, that definitely
did break the terms and conditions.
That was my view as I looked at what it
was that was done by Steven Crowder and
what the terms of service are.
Just matching it up,
not looking at the comments from
either poses specifically. It was, um,
specifically targeting an individual
on the basis of sexual orientation,
but he wasn't targeting
them on the basis of it.
He was mentioning that with his bad ideas.
He was targeting his bad ideas in
regards to Antifa a lot of that he was
dismissing Antifa but
if you look at is video,
I can't believe I spent
so much time doing this,
but that's not like a whole hour
on this two days ago. Yep. Um,
he was talking about how
Carlos just dismisses and
tiff has being not that big a
deal and that there's bias in the media
whenever there's anything negative that
happens.
But if you look at the overall picture,
and then Crowder goes on to
talk about all the assaults,
all the murders that there was
sexual assaults, there was rapes,
there was all these things
that happen with Antifa.
He was talking about all these different
people that got maced in the face,
all kinds of people that got hurt and,
and he's highlighting all,
like this is not something
to easily dismissed. Sure.
And that the FBI had labeled Antifa
a terrorist organization. So,
so far it's just politics. It's
just what, what does he think?
What do I think so far it's just that
part of it. And along the way he's like,
yeah, but the Queer Little Latino says
this. Yeah. And when he does that,
that's where it's like, okay, what is he
doing? Is He ma? He's kind of mocking him.
Right. And he's mocking
them by saying he's queer,
but he says he's queer or he says he's
gay. Yeah. But that's like saying,
I mean listen, just because the n word is
in rap songs, it doesn't mean that any,
that that defined to go and I
put the n word is not in like,
it's not like the LBGT n,
you know what I'm saying?
It's not like a part of
their, their organ. It's,
I think the principle though is you're
suggesting that because a certain word is
sometimes used self referentially by
members of a group that any use of it from
the outside is by
definition not problematic.
And I'm just saying it's more
complicated and you've got certainly more
complicated. You have to look at
specifics. I'm g I'm going from memory,
but wasn't Steven Crowder also wearing a
shirt that said fags with the a with an
asterisks, wink, wink, nudge, nudge.
It said socialism is for figs and how
he's calling a gay gay is a fig instead of
a, an eye as he's calling a gay
guy couldn't Mexico. Yes. Yeah.
I mean in total it's not
crazy. So, but no, there's a,
there's certainly an argument that,
well,
I don't necessarily think the
t shirt is for Carlos Mesa.
I think that's a t shirt that he
just has cause he thinks it's funny.
And because Che Guevara,
who's on the shirt is,
that is one of the weirdest things
that people worship. That guy,
he was a horrific human being. A
mass murderer, a terrible sociopath,
a psychopath.
And because he looks good and it in the
Cuban revolution and I'll it with a bra
on, you know, he's, he
became for a long time.
I mean it's kind of died off,
but he became like the woke poster boy.
I'm from Argentina. I know.
Uh, yeah. I was born there.
Yeah, no kidding. Yeah. Yeah.
Interesting. So I mean, listen,
here's my country bro. I made it. Um,
so listen,
I think that,
I do appreciate what you're saying and
I agree with you to a certain extent.
I believe that when
Youtube yesterday said,
we looked at the content in total and
we don't think it violates our terms and
conditions.
I disagreed with them.
I thought it very clearly violated
their terms and conditions.
Where I am thinking about it now is
the application of those terms and
conditions violations. Because a similar
thing happened with Alex Jones as well,
which was there's lots of way smaller
players that are violating the same terms
and conditions, but nobody knows about
them. Youtube doesn't know about them.
They don't get any attention
because they have no audience.
So I think there's the question of the
application of these terms and conditions,
conditions in a way that's sort of
fair and is not ultimately going by the
public blow back or reaction to situations
because that that's how I'd pocalypse
one point,
oh it happened again,
I think it was a coke ad appeared on an
obviously racist video on a channel with
like 800 or a thousand subscribers. The
Wall Street Journal, I think it was,
did an article saying,
look at these screenshots of
these advertisers on these
crazy racist videos that
led to blow back because youtube didn't
want to lose money and ultimately that's
what this is about.
I know that there are people who say
youtube has an inherently left wing bias.
Others say youtube has a of right
wing by whatever youtube is.
Bias is towards corporatism and profit.
Yes. That's fundamentally what it is.
And as a company to have a left wing bias,
I don't know that
in what sense?
Well,
in the sense that the woman who's the
CEO of Youtube was talked about it pretty
openly, like the fact that she doesn't,
what was it that she had gotten into?
Oh, well first of all was the
James Damore thing. You know,
she was talking about the Google memo
and she was talking about how it was a
incredibly damaging,
the damaging,
damaging stereotypes against women,
which it just wasn't,
it's not accurate.
Is Home Depot a right wing company
because the CEO supports Trump?
That's a good question.
Um, I'm basing it on that.
They're a part of Facebook and
Facebook is pretty clearly left wing.
Who's part of Facebook? Google. Oh,
sorry. Google. They're part of Google.
I'm at Google.
Google is a very,
very left wing group and
it's all silicon valley,
which is almost entirely left wing biased.
So I think we have to distinguish
between the personal political biases of
Silicon Valley entrepreneurs and the
broader place that Google has in the sort
of corporate sphere.
Google is part of the group of huge
multinational corporations that um,
lobbies for particular tax policy
to avoid paying taxes legally.
That is not a particularly left
wing thing to do. Uh, Google is um,
part of the large tech companies that
in order to avoid serious regulation of
their businesses have come up with this
idea of regulating themselves. Okay.
Which I know is a topic self regulation
that's come up before on your program in
in a variety of ways.
So those are not left wing things.
And if you want to make the case that as
a company it has a left wing politic in
the outward facing world,
you have to have something more than just
a lot of their engineers live in Palo
Alto and are hipsters who go to coffee
shops. You think? I think that in the,
in terms of the place that it occupies
within the economic system we have,
they are not very different from all of
the large corporations that are pushing
against regulation, pushing four
ways to avoid taxes, period.
So in terms of economic decisions,
yeah. I mean, listen, if,
if we want to talk about how the personal
politics of the employees translate to
policy,
we can do that,
but we need to be able to make some
specific claims about how, how it does,
what I'm saying is we know the way in
which the structure that Google is a part
of leads to it advocating for
things that are center, right.
Corporatist, capitalist, the
status quo of tax shelters,
havens and not paying taxes, regulating
ourselves, et Cetera, et cetera. Well,
that's what's interesting about this
crowd or things. They're ultimately,
the decision was to allow him to have
his freedom to post videos on there,
but the punitive aspect of it is
they're going to reduce his ability or
eliminated his ability to make
money. Right, right. Well,
I should say reduce, right?
Because he could, could he put
videos, just put ads up in his video?
Yeah, sure. So like we
won, one thing that I do
is we,
uh,
we kind of split off the ad sales for my
show into an ad agency and we're doing
ad sales, not just for my show,
but for other shows as well.
And those include ad placements that are
not like the pre roll ads on Youtube.
It's, the host is actually talking
about a product or whatever. It's a re,
you know, alive read sort of thing. Unbox
therapy does a lot of that. Hmm. Yeah.
That's where I first saw those who
does some pretty extensive ones. Okay.
So of course you can do that. I
mean, yeah, there's nothing he can
do that,
but he can't just collect revenue
like I assume he's been doing before.
He has a significant number
of followers. I think his, uh,
his youtube subscribers are more
than three and a half million.
So it's very high.
Yeah.
More than me and Dave just eliminated
his income that comes out of youtube.
And this was their decision based on his,
his way of talking about Carlos Mesa.
That's, that's what happened. Yeah. I
mean, so what, what are the concerns?
To me it's not that he didn't violate
terms and conditions. Like I said,
I think he pretty clearly did
the concerns to me are um,
is youtube only going to even look into
these circumstances or instances when
there is a public outcry?
The answer is probably yes because why
would they look into stuff nobody's
paying attention to.
It's not a good use of change.
Their decision based on public outcry,
based on Carl's mazes,
reaction to the initial decision.
I happen to think their initial
decision was the wrong one.
But I have a sort of broader concern here,
which is about the fairness of the
application and also the distinguishing
between a content that is
promoting whatever falls
under any of our definitions
of hateful or whatever content and
those who are fighting against it.
So is it because he mentioned his sexual
orientation and that he called him a
list, be little queer or whatever,
you call them, more queer Mexican.
And if he just called him a fucking idiot
and he received the exact same amount
of hate, would you still think
that that was a good move?
No.
I mean,
I think that it would not fall under
what they are now claiming is the
justification for the demonetization.
It would be different because
it would have the same, yeah.
Result.
The only difference would be they wouldn't
be attacking his sexual orientation
specifically because of crowd.
That's the only difference.
It's policing speech,
you know? It really is.
Here's a,
so who gets to decide if
not the private businesses,
what their rules are.
That's
where the real question comes up.
Right?
Tulsi Gabbert believes that it's a first
amendment issue and she believes that
everyone should have the freedom of
expression and then as long as you're not
doing anything illegal,
you're not putting anyone to danger by
giving up their address or doxing them or
something along those lines or
making overt physical threats. Right.
That you should allowed to do that because
that's what the freedom of speech
is all about. And freedom of speech.
When you eliminate social media
in this country is your, your,
your freedom is basically, yes. Yelling,
yelling out in public. I mean you're,
we're in this weird place. It's
always a culture. As a culture.
It's unprecedented really in terms of
the waters we're navigating right now,
there's a couple of different things to,
so I like the principal,
like my principal is,
we do almost no moderation on any of
our platforms that my program is on.
My only thing that I tell my team is if
you see something that really seems to
be illegal, it's calling for violence, it,
whatever the these are, we have a very,
very high bar before we will
remove anything. And quite frankly,
we're just too busy. Do you mean by that?
I'm confused. Like who's not your videos?
Whose videos?
So if we find out that on our videos,
someone is posting endless comments
in the comment. Second comment,
my personal view is if it's not illegal,
I just, just let it all be there and sit.
That's my personal view. And that's
a great principle to have. Well,
we don't touch them. We leave them
alone. Even though we get accused of it,
but the,
the question is youtube at one point in
time had thrown out there that they were
going to make people responsible for
the things that were in their comments.
I vaguely remember that.
But it didn't ultimately think they
backed out of it very quickly when they
realize that places like yours,
right.
Which like your average video gets how
many thousands of comments a lot and many
of them antisemitic.
And how would you, yeah.
And how would you even be able
to look at all those? I mean,
you would have to be 24 seven monitoring.
I'm Bryce.
You've also got people that are watching
your videos from overseas at all times
in the night.
Yup.
So I think that the principle of only
only illegal content will be removed is
great. That's, uh, that's my
personal principle. However,
I think that there is no serious case
to be made that a private company can't
say these are our terms of service.
And if you want to, I mean,
it's sort of almost a
conservative principle, right?
The idea that unless illegal
things are going on, uh,
we are not going to tell a business
how it is that it should be run.
And that's where I think a lot of right
wingers start to stumble on this issue
because they're calling for a very
invasive form of government regulation.
They're calling for the government
to step in and even break up these
organizations because they've
gotten too large. And,
but you're hearing that
from the left as well? Yeah.
Well I think there's a difference.
There's a difference though between
Elizabeth Warren saying we should separate
the social platform Facebook from the
ad sales revenue generating piece of it.
That's one thing that
falls under antitrust.
That's different than
saying the government should
come in and it should tell
anybody who runs a social
network that you can't even,
you can't do anything unless the content
is illegal because there are financial
considerations, right? I mean there's
lots of content that would not be illegal,
but it would make a platform
video platform like youtube
not financially viable
because advertisers would see it and
they'd say, oh, we're not going near that.
Right.
So I have a very hard time taking what
is a very authoritarian perspective that
the government should come in and say,
this is how social networks should be run.
Now if you want to change the law,
here's the way it could be done.
If you want to change the law and argue
that these platforms have gotten so big
that they represent more of
a town square so to speak,
then okay, maybe you could pass a law
that changes how they would be regulated,
but that's typically the type of stuff
the right is against because it is more
regulation.
It is more regulation,
but it's regulation to keep a private
company from regulating against free
speech. Do you see what I'm saying?
It's, it's a sneaky kind of regulation.
It's a regulation that's enforcing the
first amendment and the people's ability
to freely express themselves if we're
admitting or if we're agreeing that we are
entering into this new
world. Yes. Where this is I,
that's my position is that
it is a town square and I,
I feel like everybody should
be able to communicate.
The really unfortunate,
unsavory aspect of it is when someone
gets harassed like Carlos Mesa was because
of this,
where people are sending him all these
homophobic tweets and all the in these
getting text messages and all this shit.
That's,
that's the unsavory and unfortunate
aspect of it. And how do you stop that?
I don't know how you stop it.
I don't know exactly how you stop it,
but I think it would be useful.
I mean,
one thing is when does a platform get
big enough in your mind that it would
qualify for this like town square
designation? Well for sure. Youtube.
Let's talk about that one.
Cause that's the one we're on.
I mean fucking God damn it.
It's huge. It's gigantic.
So are there other types of businesses
through which communication happens that
you think should be regulated in the
same way? That's not really clear.
So I'll give an example.
Okay.
If you start regularly
sending people via ups,
uh,
similar things to some of the content
that exists on youtube and ups says we're
getting reports that you're
sending people harassing stuff,
we don't want you as a customer anymore.
Here's the question though,
isn't there a difference between someone
sending something to a physical address
and someone sending something?
Just let's say to you when your social
media apps or on the third page of your
phone and you have to swipe all the way
over to get them and open it up and you
have to read them.
If you want to find them,
well you don't necessarily
have to read them.
There's a difference in a practical sense,
but I guess the question is
would we want the government,
would you similarly want the government
to enforce for telephone companies?
If you are harassment, getting harassing
texts and you report it and report it,
that's a different thing.
I think.
I think what's coming to your
phone and the phone is ringing.
I think that's a another step.
It's another step towards invasive.
It's a big gray area. Is the phone
ringing? Is it a phone call? Is it a text?
Is it it? Is it a whatsapp message to
read that text? Right? Yeah. No, I feel
you.
I guess where I hesitate,
and again I'm speaking of someone from
the left who believes regulation of
businesses is an important thing I
would want to be really sure about how
exactly it is that the government would
step in and mandate essentially that
their view has to be listened to over
the terms of service that a private
company you would wish to have.
Yes.
I feel like when you give people a gun,
they start looking for targets and the,
that is a very common thing.
If you give people the ability to censor
and give people the ability to censor
based on their political ideology or
based on what they feel is offensive or
other people don't. It's a slippery
slope and I think that that can,
that can lead to all sorts.
Look that woman,
what is her name again?
The one who tried to get Amy Siskind.
Imagine her being in charge of a social
media platform should try to get you
fired from Boston College for something
that was incredibly polite. Right.
That is what I'm talking about
is there are very action,
that very same type of thinking
that she tried to impose on you.
That's what I'm worried about.
I'm worried about people that are
really strictly trying to promote their
ideologies and what they think is okay
and not okay and it's very slippery cause
there's a lot of weird people out there
that believe a lot of weird things and
want other people to conform
to those weird things.
And we sort of have to decide like
that's why I'm bringing up this crowd or
thing like do I think that
what he said was good? No,
it's not nice to call someone a
little lispy queer. It's not nice.
It's kind of mean,
you know?
And especially when that guy
wasn't even engaging with him.
But he's making fun of him. He's
a comedy show. He's mocking them.
So the question becomes like when,
when is that mocking considered homophobic
and when is it just ribbing? Right.
And that's his position.
His position is that it's just ribbing.
This is the problem with a discussion
that is only about the principles.
So like a lot of our conversation for
the last 15 minutes has been what is our
principal about,
what types of business regulation is
okay for the government to do and is not
okay.
Or when we talk about free speech,
what should do we have a principle of
anything short of illegal content versus
something that is more strict?
The reality is that it's it,
there's more gray area.
Yeah.
We're trying to sort of regulate the
way people communicate with each other.
So it's not, it's like if someone
said that to someone in a bar,
a cop would not arrest them. Like yeah,
you listen a little queer, you know,
that would be like, oh, that guy's
basil. But the bar would be perfectly
within their legal right to say, we don't,
we don't want you in here.
You're making our customers uncomfortable.
And nobody would say that. It would
be against the law for the bar to say,
you got to go.
That's a good point.
If they were doing it to their face.
But what if he was in a corner talking
about this guy that wasn't there?
And he was saying,
yeah,
so he's talking about Antifa
has lispy little Mexican queer.
If you came along and decided to
kick the guy out of the bar, then
it would, I mean, listen at some bars,
if you go into the corner and you yell
about Alyssa, right? Mexican queer,
they're going to ask you to leave.
And it still would not be illegal and the
bar would still not be doing anything.
Right. But that's a bar, right?
That's a private business where
people are physically there. Yes.
Isn't there a difference between
that and something like Youtube,
which again falls more in
line with like a town square?
Maybe that's what we need to revisit that
because so much human communication is
now happening across these platforms. I
would imagine most of it, or most of it,
we know we need to maybe stop drawing
this arbitrary distinction that in person
is a completely different thing
than over the Internet. I mean,
maybe it's not increasingly, maybe
it's more the same. Yeah. Um,
so I'm torn here, right?
On one side I say, well,
it seems like they still allow him to
have his freedom of expression because
he's still on youtube. He still is
able to upload his show on Youtube.
He will have to find other
ways to make money. Sure.
So one part of me looks at it that way
and no one has a right to monetize on
youtube. Right? Right. So in a sense,
they haven't violated his first amendment
rights because he's still able to
express himself.
But then you go as a company,
they've made a punitive decision to
eliminate his ability or is radically
reduced his ability to make an
income off of their platform.
That seems like, and I'm not
supporting that, they did it,
but that seems more
reasonable as a decision,
right. To say we're going to demonetize
you. That seems more reasonable.
But the problem is
there's no alternatives.
There's nothing remotely like Youtube to
over there is an alternative to youtube
for him to regain that same
level of monetization. Yes.
Or for people that share his viewpoint
and share his ideology and chair his
positions. And there's no right
wing. Youtube is my point.
And there's this like I would challenge
the idea that youtube is, is left wing.
I mean in terms of it's
enforcing its policies. How so?
I mean they had just this, just this
particular issue, but this isn't,
this isn't a left wing.
How is this a left wing enforcement?
I mean they think it is because Carl's
mazes progressive and because the
argument that he was making is a very
left wing progressive argument and this is
what Crowder was going after.
He was going after the argument in the
process of going after the argument,
he mocked his sexuality
and his appearance.
I can assure you if it was focused merely
on how much of a problem Antifa is,
this would not have happened.
I mean I think we both, oh
yeah, for sure. Yeah. No,
it's all about the mocking the
guys sexual orientation and looks.
That's worth Carlos Maza where a gay
Republican and the exact same thing
happened. Do you think the outcome
would've been different? Yes. Why?
I just don't think people be
interested. Oh, well that's a dip up.
But so that gets to the real crux of it,
which is my real concern with this is
youtube only getting involved in even
publicly saying what they're
doing about a channel,
right?
When it becomes very public and it starts
to have the possibility of impacting
their bottom line and brand saying, yes,
this is too hot and we're getting out.
Well in that sense what Carlos did once
it was revealed that youtube was not
going to take action was very effective.
Absolutely.
I mean he started tweeting like
crazy and people jumped on board.
He connected it to the LBGT movement and,
and then it became this thing.
I mean the other side of this is,
I mean I don't know if we even want to
go into identity politics so to speak,
but there has,
I've s I've read some comments on some
of the few articles that have been
written about this that are saying that
this is effectively youtube enforcing a
defense of identity politics, so to
speak. And I think that that's just again,
opening up the door to the incredibly
broad application of that term identity
politics. I don't even really fully
understand that, but I don't know.
And I don't even know if that's
a path we want to go down to.
Talk about like the identity politics
component of what's going on with a lot of
this regulation. Find what you mean by the
identity politics of it. I mean listen,
so I guess in order to
define it, define it, I,
it would be good to point out that uh,
I have been critical of quote identity
politics on the left in a very limited
way that I think it is actually damaging
while at the same time recognizing that
identity is a really important thing to
consider when we think about sort of how
the world should be organized.
So like for your audience who may not
know when identity politics is used,
you know,
like a,
like a knife to enforce that
because of someone's identity,
their opinion supersedes
and is the opinion that is
the valid one over everybody
else because of membership in some
kind of group. I'm against that.
I think that's extremely destructive.
It would be very,
uh,
incorrect to believe though that
identity doesn't play a role and that we
shouldn't understand how one's identity
might make us think differently about
certain issues. I mean, any example
would sure would make that pretty clear,
you know, I, as an immigrant
to the United States,
do I get some privileged
position to decide what policy
should be overall native
born Americans because I immigrated here?
No,
that would meet be me using identity
politics is like a mallet or a cuddle or
whatever, but as someone who did
immigrate here, we should recognize that.
I may have things to say about it,
which would be valuable and worthy and
important to sort of think about it.
That's my shore on identity politics.
You're just not interested in the
hierarchy of oppressed people.
I'm not interested in the oppression
Olympics and they're not interested in
using identity to silence ideas that could
be perfectly good coming from someone
who is not a member or checking a
certain box. Exactly. Nor Am I. I,
I strongly believe in the individual and
I think it's one of the most important
parts of a collective
group of human beings like our country
than we recognize that we're all
different and there's a lot of weirdness
amongst us but are individuals and I
like to treat people
based on who they are,
not what classification they fall under.
Now do you think that that bad version
of identity politics that I mentioned is
a big problem on the left or
not a big problem? I'm curious.
I think it's certainly a problem,
but I think it's a vocal minority problem.
That's what I think.
I think if you just regular people that
are on the left that are working jobs
and having families and
doing their hobbies and they
just have left wing ideas,
I don't think the vast majority
of them hold those positions.
I think those positions are
things that people use as revenue.
I mean not as revenue, but it's like they,
they, they get points from it, you know,
they,
they get points from certain types of
behavior that they support certain types
of thinking that they support.
And it,
it lets you know you've got woke social
justice points and then we agree. Yeah.
I mean I, Jen I asked because
I genuinely didn't know.
I mean I've heard them talking about
any politics dangerous number though in
terms of college campuses,
when you look at like what
happened in Evergreen state,
Bret Weinstein, it, it, it,
it's very disruptive.
Yes and no.
I mean I do think that it's
disproportionately a PR.
I think it's a small
problem like you're saying.
I think a lot of the problem exists
in the college campus setting,
but um, I mean even at
Boston College, you know,
I had sort of maybe been incorrectly,
um,
indoctrinated into the idea that this was
really a problem everywhere on college
campuses and I had an incident,
the details of which wouldn't
be appropriate to talk about,
but with a student when I taught at
Boston college that because of the
circumstances and the identities involved,
I was ready for it to go into.
This is going to be resolved the wrong
way on the basis of the toxic identity
politics I'm hearing is existing on
college campuses. And it was not,
it was the exact opposite.
So I think the same way that
when you look at Yelp reviews,
people who had a bad experience are way
more likely to go and write about it.
Yes.
These individual stories get way more
attention than the percentage of the
problem that they represent. I believe
you're probably correct about that,
but when you see videos like
nick, Nick Christakis getting, uh,
just shouted down at Yale by a group
of students and that they supported the
students and that kind of Shit, you
say, well, it is real. It does exist.
It's real. It exists. I think that
sensible people on the left like me,
uh, call it out, but I want to be careful.
Imagine that you had someone
from Cato on the show,
which is sort of like a traditional
conservative or American Enterprise
Institute.
Maybe he's like a better example.
And a lot of the conversation was about
getting them to talk about or denounced
the alt right, for example.
I'm sure they would do it,
but how much should a
denounced the outright when
that's like a different thing
sample?
Yeah. It's a very good analogy. Yeah.
I think we oftentimes are responding
to this very vocal minority.
Yes.
And those are the people that are most
invested in getting these ideas pushed
through and they're there. It's
also people that, you know,
for lack of a better term,
they're probably mentally ill and I only
mean mentally ill in terms of like have
like legitimate diseases.
But in terms of their thought patterns,
they're probably obsessive. I mean
I've had friends that were, uh,
especially friends that were heavily
involved in this kind of stuff before and
it was very damaging to their
mental health, this type of stuff,
being politics being woke,
left wing,
shout out at people
attack people politics.
But then you realize somewhere
on the wine and then one of them,
my friend Jamie Kilstein was a, they
turned on him and then, you know,
devastated his life and he realized
along the way like, oh Jesus Christ.
Like what?
What was I doing?
Like I was checking my Twitter every five
seconds and insulting people left and
right. And attacking people just to get
everybody to say, yeah, go get him. And,
you know, showing everybody how
woke I am and how progressive I am.
And it becomes a weird sort of a,
a point system.
Like you're, you're trying
to score points, you're,
you're trying to gain
favor with your party.
There's a lot of that.
I think it's really important though.
So there's people on the left and right
who get pulled into political wokeness,
whether it's I'm now tea party in 2010
people that got sucked into tea party on
the right and Tifo whatever.
These are all groups with different sort
of followings. They're not all the same,
whatever.
I do think that there is a difference
between getting extremely passionate about
the idea that everybody should have
access to just basic health care.
Then getting extremely
passionate about the idea, uh,
that we need to go out of our way to
shut down every abortion clinic in the
country. I think that there's
just, there's a difference.
So I don't want to participate
in a false equivalency between,
well,
you got very far left in very far right
people and they're the same and you've
got center left and center right.
And they're the same.
It's just two sides of the same coin.
Like obviously I have a perspective
that is based on my politics.
I'm glad to debate any of these issues
with anybody who wants to on the merits,
but I don't want to make the
false equivalency. I mean, listen,
when you look at Anti Defamation
League numbers, for example,
the vast majority of, um, of,
of hate incidents in the United
States are coming from the right.
We could talk about other
ways that the left is active.
We could talk about what it means
or how things should be categorized,
but that's the reality.
And so I want to make sure I don't
play a false equivalency game.
My audience would crush me if
I did that, number one. Um,
but I think it's just wrong.
I think it's wrong to do that.
I don't think the facts bear it out.
I think you're right there.
And I also think that these
false equivalency kind of
conversations or they're
ridiculous because each individual
conversation about each individual issue
deserves its own discussion.
Yes. And to say, what about this?
Or what about that? Those? What about
Isms? Those are the, the death of
any real rational discussion
because they go on forever.
There they go on forever. There's
no, I mean it's like scroll,
this is why scrolling Twitter endlessly
is a problem because there's really no
end. You can always scroll a little new
to it to the end for right. Yeah. I mean,
yeah,
the it's the new tweets are coming fast.
It's the same with a lot of those kind
of one's ever done that just scrolled
until their phone died.
Just charge it,
wake up in the morning and just scroll
down all day. How long does it take?
I think you wouldn't because the new
content appears faster because of the
algorithm, but you still never
run out? No. Just keep going. No.
There's a few things. I don't know if
this would be interesting to go into,
but there's a few things that I've
found have been somewhat successful in
conversations with people
who really disagree with me
and at least like lowering
the temperature a little bit and getting
people to maybe engage in a good faith
way. One of them is how do you
think I came to my position?
Mm.
So you might be four total free
market for profit healthcare.
I am for a system where the government
is more involved and even if you can't
pay, you get care before
we even start. If I say,
how do you think I arrived at my
position? That has been pretty useful. Um,
another example is,
uh,
I think this came from Peter Bogosian
who I think you've had on, yes.
The Duffy's ability question,
which is what evidence if I presented it
to you would bring you over to my side.
I'm not saying I have that
evidence or that it exists,
but give me a framework as to what is
keeping you from seeing this my way.
Because sometimes that exists,
the person just doesn't know about it.
Those are two tools that I have found
super useful in trying to make some
headway with people who are hyper
partisan and very escalated with a lot of
these issues.
Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. It's,
it's very difficult to have good faith
conversations with people when you
disagree with them.
You know,
and you have to have discipline and you
have to have some sort of a sense of
self. Yeah. And you have to
know how to be calm and kind,
you know, the, the, the,
the descent into insults and
dunking on people as one of the,
one of the reasons why I,
at the beginning of the conversation,
I was saying that I've,
one of the things I enjoy about your,
your youtube videos is
you're a very reasonable,
rational person and you don't get
crazy and animated and insulting.
And I think there's,
we need more of that because I think
even though you're not going to convert
some people,
there's just a certain subsection of
the population that disagrees with you
that's just going to write. But there's
a significant number that I going to go,
hey, this David Pakman guys, he's
reasonable. He's making a lot of sense.
He's intelligent.
Well,
my goal is,
and I think that it's sort of working and
that we have a lot of Trump supporters
who are paid subscribers
to my show. A, we have some
are they taking notes? Uh, maybe they
are to the boss, but my, uh, my goal is,
my goal is, yeah, that would, I mean that,
that would be an interesting day if I
wake up and Trump has responded to one of
my videos about him, what would you
do? Uh, I think it'd be a good day.
Well,
that's what Cole bear did.
That was how funny was that when Cole
Bear was on TV's like Donald? Yeah.
How did you not know that you shouldn't
respond to me? Right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's rule number one.
It's an important one.
Unless you want to create a shit
storm of a very certain email.
My goal is I don't pretend to be neutral.
I think neutrality is almost always
false because on most issues, people,
they're not indifferent. I mean neutral
is another way of saying in different,
you could be conflicted in neutral,
you can be conflicted in neutral,
but I try to at least be objective and
transparent in how I arrived at what I
believe,
so you can disagree with my conclusion.
You can even come to me
and telling me the facts.
I've used to reach the conclusion
or incomplete or wrong,
but I'm completely genuine and how I
arrived there and I think that that is why
we have some, I mean,
yeah, there's obviously,
if you look at Youtube comments that
are right wingers that watch my show,
but choosing to support it financially
is a different thing and I get emails
from conservatives who say,
I don't agree with your conclusions,
but I do find that you're at least
reasoning through the issues in a way that
resonates with me and I want to support
the fact that you're doing that.
That's outstanding.
That's a huge victory.
There really is in a sense in
my eyes is in this day and age,
I think this is the most polarized time.
I can remember as a 51 year old man
looking back at my history of paying
attention to social issues and the way
we communicate with each other and just
to partisan attitudes that people
seem to have. I don't, I don't,
I mean I think it's probably because
of Trump. That's a giant part of it,
but it's also just a sign of
the times of social media.
I think it's in part engineered by the
algorithms at Facebook and Twitter and
all these other social
media companies utilize.
And it's also been engineered by Beth bad
faith participants and people that are
actually manipulating it.
Um,
I don't know if you've paid any
attention to Sam Harris had a fantastic a
podcast with a,
and we had one with her as well.
Rene de Resta when they arrest a analyzed
all of the various accounts that the
IRA had created,
would the internet research agency that
was responsible for all of these fake
accounts that people thought were black
lives matter accounts or pro southern
secession accounts or all these different
accounts that were very polarizing and
arguing with other people that these
were just Russians that were working for
this organization that was
specifically trying to start chaos.
They were specifically trying
to start arguments and when you,
when you,
you see that and then I mean that's
a factor.
That's a giant factor.
That kind of shit is a factor and that
that is sort of become part of the sport
of social media has been arguing.
Absolutely. I don't do it. I don't engage,
but I do go on Facebook sometimes when
someone makes an abortion post and I just
watched the chaos like, oh my God. Yeah,
it's in or anything having anything to
do with Trump or anything having anything
to do with the second
amendment or anything that has
anything to do with the the
wall or immigration.
So I don't know that people are
actually enlarger disagreements,
right, than they were
previously. I think that yes,
Trump has coarsened the language and
the way in which it's now acceptable to
talk about a lot of these things.
That's number one.
I think the social media algorithms
like you're pointing out,
reward the most extreme and polarizing
comments and reactions in a never ending
feedback loop where the most polarizing
initial tweet generates a more risky,
more responses than less polarizing
tweets and then the sub responses that are
most polarizing and and aggressive do the
exact same thing and it's never ending
feedback loop.
I think it's all those things,
but I don't know that people are having
bigger disagreements than in times past.
I just think that they're
public in a different way.
Well,
there's more disagreements because
people have more opportunity to disagree,
so they have more opportunity to engage.
In particular when you're talking about
people that are addicted to their phones
and it's coming from a guy who uses
fucking phone four hours a day.
I'd like to think that one
hour that is productive,
but I know that three hours of it
is me staring at butts on Instagram,
looking at muscle cars and watching crazy
videos. And then how much are you on?
Like a computer? I don't
know. Hmm. I didn't, I don't
have that, that data. Right,
but it's not as much and mow,
the good thing about it is most of
my bullshit I'm doing on the phone,
most of my computer work,
unless I'm laying in bed and I just watch,
embarrassingly enough, I watch youtube
videos on pool. That's what I watch real.
I go to bed. Yeah,
that's interesting. Well,
I play pool so I'll watch
like professional pool
matches before I go to bed
because it's calming, it's relaxing and
I analyze positions. It's interesting.
I do the same thing with
chess. Ah, that's what I,
there's like chest streamers that
I watch and it's similar. It's key.
You could kick back and sort of, it's,
you're engaged. But it's nothing crazy.
And it's also kind of stimulating
in an intellectual way or, yeah,
it's different than
politics. Yes, yes, yes.
Like on weekends when people, you
know, like my mom will, you know,
I want to talk to me about politics
and I'm just like, I did this all week,
mom and your mom watch your show.
She does.
And she watches other shows and my family,
super political,
so real and so on the weekends,
if it's Saturday,
I'm right in the middle of my break
period because they left wing. Oh yeah.
Thank God. Yeah. I imagine,
could you imagine some
mean dad calling you up? What the
fuck is wrong with you, David?
I might've had to de fu.
Ah, de fu. Mm. Yeah, yeah.
Anyway. Anyway, indeed. Um,
I think that there's more opportunity
as her saying, to descend,
to disagree with people,
more opportunity to argue.
And in those more opportunities
you're seeing more conflict.
And I think more polarization.
And I think, again,
the social media algorithms and
all the other nonsense that gets,
I think there's, I really do believe
that the, the feeling that I get,
but it also might be because a big part
of my job is being on the Internet.
So maybe I'm more engaged with it.
RV folks skews it a little bit. Yeah.
But I think, so in practice it, Matt,
let's imagine that the disagreements
are equal to what they've always been,
but there's more opportunities to
disagree and the algorithm favors more
escalated disagreement
than rational conversation.
The effect is that you might meet someone
with whom you have 80% in common in
terms of your political views,
but the circumstances in which you engage
with that person are going to be on
the 20% that you don't.
So it makes it seem as though you just
have very little common ground with
anybody,
right.
Because the 80% agreement becomes
background and the social media platforms,
the debates happening on youtube elsewhere
are focused only on like the most
divisive fraction of one's entire
political views. And that's,
I think what the problem is.
Mm.
But it makes sense because
most people agree that,
I don't know gas stations.
I mean just to pick something innocuous.
Most people agree that it's good to
have a regulatory system that makes sure
that when you think you've
pumped five gallons of gas,
you've gotten five gallons of gas,
it's so uncontroversial that
nobody's going to talk about it.
Like it makes sense that the focus
is going to be on the disagreements.
Where it's damaging is then when you
meet people in real life and it's hard to
relate or even be in the same room
because only those differences are sort of
like played up.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes. Yeah. Yeah, but
the conflict gets highlighted.
You have conflict bias. Yeah. Yeah. I,
I don't know where I see this going.
That's one of the more interesting things
about particularly with social media
and like things when you come
to this crowd or situation,
I don't know where this is going cause I
didn't know this was ever going to be a
thing. I had never really considered that
there was going to be some digital town
square that we're all
going to be enjoying.
Whether it's Twitter or
youtube or whatever it is
that might even need,
right.
Yeah. That might even need regulation.
But getting back to the Crowder thing,
um,
the issue that you,
so you agree with it in the sense that
he was mocking this person's sexual
orientation and appearance.
I agree with the assertion that Youtube's
terms of service as written were
violated on the basis that he was
singling out an individual and the
characteristics that that
individual was being, uh,
targeted with or spoken were,
uh,
sexual orientation in
terms that, that, um, uh,
the terms of service say is not allowed.
Is that different in your opinion than
someone singling something out for what
you believe is their mental incompetency?
Well, the mental and comp,
do you mean that they are in
marketing or that they're,
that they're mentally ill
or cognitively limited,
cognitively limited, mocking their ability
to think, walking their intelligence,
mocking their decisions, mocking
their, the way they talk,
and then encouraging other
people to do the same thing.
And then that person gets harassed
based on their intelligence,
based on their performance on particular
youtube videos and conversations.
And there's active harassers,
there's people that do that.
Is there a difference between,
say what Sam Cedar does to Dave Rubin?
What does Sam do to Dave Ruben? He has,
I don't know that I seen that video.
Dozens of videos.
Don't say that video.
He has dozens of videos where
he's just dunking on Dave Rubin.
So I, I mean I, I have some
as well. I believe that they
are substantive. That's my,
my view is that my video is about
Dave Rubin or substantive. I really,
I don't really watch any left wing stuff
because I want to try to isolate myself
enough to make sure that what I'm saying
are my id is unique and that I'm not
taking them. So I know Sam's a friend
of mine and I, oh, that's interesting.
And a comics do though.
I don't know.
But if there some specific examples
we could comment about them. But, um,
I think that there too, to your first
question, there is a difference, uh,
between going after someone
for sexual orientation, right.
Then going after them for the fact that
they say things that are wrong or don't
know stuff until you're making fun of
someone who has an actual handicap of some
kind, some kind of, you know, uh,
limited cognitive limitation that
would be a disability of some kind.
Then you are mocking
someone for a decision.
The resulting effect of the harassment.
The,
see this is what I was getting
at before with Crowder.
Like what Crowder said was one thing,
but one of the things that Carlos Mesa
was discussing was what the people that
had watch Crowder,
what they were doing,
how they were going after him as if
see that and that is a real discussion.
Like what,
what happens when you say something about
someone and then your fans agree and
then they take action.
Which I didn't see that in the Steven
Crowder decision that the reaction was
part of youtube evaluation.
Now I may just have missed that,
but I didn't see youtube say that part
of the calculation had to do with what
other people were.
I don't think they did say that
and I don't think they would,
but I think Carlos Mesa did say that
it was one of the things that he was
talking about this endless assault.
He's experienced.
Well he's right to, uh,
call it deplorable. I think
we would agree with that.
I think your question is
more about whether you choose
who's responsible for it,
where is responsible for it.
Yeah.
He's anonymous.
People that can just lash out at someone
and insult them out of ultimately
they are responsible. Those people
respond. People tend to agree. However,
um,
so there's this term stochastic terrorism,
I dunno if you're familiar
with the Catholic terrorism,
is the idea that if you have
a big enough audience, um,
and you go and every day you're talking
about someone should really do something
about a particular politician,
you're doing it every day.
You're doing every day,
uh,
at a certain point,
given a large enough audience
and enough repetition of that.
And the fact that there's like a
distribution of people's emotional states,
cognitive capacity,
et Cetera,
it is statistically probable that someone
from that audience is going to go and
try to do something about whoever
it is that you're targeting.
That individual who has the show and is
hammering on this person day after day
after day,
they're not going to be
legally responsible for that
person from their audience
who went and did something.
There's no way that you're going to
hold them legally responsible under the
current legal system that we have,
but you could argue that
it is irresponsible in some
way not to understand that
your consequences have actions.
Of course,
the person who goes and does the
violent act is the primary person who is
responsible, right? But as long as
you're not calling out for that act,
how do we make this distinction that
someone is encouraging that act or someone
is at least inspiring that their
judgment calls? I mean, listen,
I can go on my show and I can speak
in vague terminology or specific
terminology. You know,
imagine that there's a local
business that I don't like.
I could go on my show and I could
say this business did this and I need
everybody in my audience to show up
there and to make it impossible to get in
and patronize that business. That's very
clearly on one side of the gray area.
I could instead say, you know, uh,
there's a business and I could say the
type of business, but I not, not name it.
If it's a small enough town,
people would know exactly what business
I'm talking about and I really don't
like the way I was treated there.
And if only there was some way that
someone could do something about it,
the effect could be the exact same on it.
Right.
I don't know how you measure when it's
on one side and yeah. It's like, yeah,
right.
You could somehow or another remove your,
you're, you could somehow or
another make it so that it's, yeah,
I'm agreeing with you.
Yeah. You can remove your
responsibility for their actions.
Some sort of what was just got
interesting. Uh, um, I was just,
I was trying to find a tweet from Mazda
about him sending or asking people to
flag Crowder's videos.
Did you get the one where he asked people
to go assault people with milkshakes?
So he ate them at every turn you
to tweet it an hour ago or yeah,
1230 that to clarify, this is
responding to Carlos Mazda to clarify.
In order to restate
monetization on his channel,
he will need to remove the link to his
t shirts. Oh, so it's the figs t shirt?
Yeah.
Oh well that's all he has to do.
He specifically asked about
that and then they respond.
That's why I have to do wow.
That's well using. That's pretty,
pretty straightforward. It's pretty
straight forward. Yeah. The shirts stupid.
But you know, he's a comedian.
I mean that's a crowd is doing.
And his doing the thing about Mesa,
he's mocking him for his appearance.
But Carlos Mesa specifically encouraged
people to throw milkshakes at people
that disagree with him and to harass
them publicly and humiliate them.
So one thing that does not justify
the other, no, it doesn't have that.
But that is more egregious.
How fast can people to assault people
and asking people to physically humiliate
people in person, in my
opinion, is more egregious.
I don't agree with mocking his physical
a p well as physical appearances.
That's just what it is, you know? But
the sexual orientation aspect of it,
it's like, yeah, I get it, I get it. It's
not, it's not nice. How far do you think,
sorry,
this is just a comedian thing goes
because I hear that a lot in just excusing
things that are said. He's trying to do
comedy, right? So He's trying to make fun.
Izzy yell,
hold on,
but make comedy and making fun of
someone are two different things.
Like I don't do comedy, but
I will sometimes make fun
of things people say. Right.
But he's doing it to be funny.
He's making fun of things specifically
to be funny. And sometimes you know,
when you do that, you go
too far, you cross lines.
I genuinely did not realize that Crowder
does a comedy show. Oh yeah, yeah.
He's so when he, so when show is a comedy
show. Wow. Yeah. A lot of it is funny.
He does some funny shit.
He really does.
Whether you agree with them or disagree
with them. He's done some hilarious bits.
I genuinely, I'm, I'm reacting
in real time because I had
no idea. He has his spit.
He does about this French socialists.
He puts on a wig and pretends
to be this different person.
He's pretending to be a
transgender person is pretended to.
He's done a bunch of these
infiltration videos. We'll,
he'll go into these ridiculous
organizations and ask them questions,
but it's very much a comedy show
dressing up like a trans person's funny.
It is. If you're funny at
it, if you could, I mean, Mrs
Doubtfire isn't that funny?
And that's what he was doing.
He was dressing up as a woman.
He was dressing up as a woman,
right.
He was dressing up as a woman
and that's a great movie.
I agree with you there over
there's some funny shit.
And look how many times and in living
color did they dress up like women,
there's,
there's some humor to someone who is
a man who's dressing up like a woman.
Sure. That can, that can be an,
I shouldn't comment specifically on
crowd or doing it if I hadn't seen it.
Now he's got some funny shit he does.
You know.
And I'll take shit for that for saying
that. He's funny. He makes me laugh too.
I'm staying quiet. Yeah I
know, I understand. I get it.
I don't agree with him.
You know constantly going on and on about
this guy being queer are calling them
a lispy little queer but he's
doing it to try to be funny.
So the question is when can
you do that to be funny?
And apparently with youtube you can do
that and be funny as long as you were
always on the tee shirt tee
shirt. Yeah. This is interesting
actually. Even that's even weirder
now this is weird that they just,
if he removes a t shirt of link, a link
to the tee shirt, oh he can still sell it.
He just can't link to it from Youtube.
I think that's what they're saying.
That's so minor that it's hard to,
I mean it is what it is
cause it's sort of an encouraging people
to buy it. And then youtube would say,
well,
if you have an add on that,
then you're encouraging homophobic
behavior and we can allow that with our
monetization policy.
I mean it's minor in the
context of everything else
that's wrapped up in this I
buy it might be an important fun,
you know,
revenue generating tee shirt for
I think so much of this, again,
these disagreements on issues,
it comes down to what you
and I were talking about
before that if two people are
in a room together,
95% of what they're talking about,
you're going to agree on when
someone's making a video on someone.
If they just to say like
fucking David Pakman man, I,
here's my deal with that guy and then
you just ranting thing and is I hate his
fucking neck and I don't like
his shirt and his face is stupid.
When people do stuff like
that, it's just, it's a,
it's a terrible way to communicate
because it's, first of all,
you would have to be a real asshole to
say most of the things that people say
about things and they're dunking
on them in person. You have to be,
you used to be a bad person,
so you know the person's going to see it.
So you're just deciding I'm
going to be a bad person,
but I'm pretend I'm not a bad person
because I'm going to do it in a way where
they're not in the room, so I'm just going
to shit all over him and give him my,
my real opinion.
But it's not like a real,
it's not like you and I are at dinner
and you're like, you know, fuck this guy.
And that's, that's how people
talk. But when you're doing that,
but you're doing it,
you're broadcasting it.
I think we're all learning in this process
of doing podcasts and video blogs on
this stuff.
We're all learning that you're not alone.
You are doing this and you're saying it
in a way that that person's going to see
in the same, could be applied to, uh,
Dave Ruben and Sam Cedar
dunking on them all the time.
It's kind of the same thing.
And Michael Roberts as well.
So same sort of thing there. That
that's what they're doing. Yeah.
And they're saying things that they
wouldn't say if he was there in person.
Right. But sure. Okay. Guilty. They were
sitting around having lunch together,
talking shit about some stupid
thing that he said the night before.
Yeah, that, that's
fine. And I don't think,
I mean whether or not you
would say something in person
doesn't tell us whether
it's a fair or unfair critique.
True.
I think it's fair to say I try to avoid
strict ad hominems I will, I mean listen,
we're all trying to get,
build an audience, right?
So at a certain point, yes.
Like I will pick titles that I think
are the most interesting titles to get
people to watch the thing or whatever.
Or I'll use vocabulary that
I might not use in person,
but at least what I'm trying to do is
make it as substantive as possible and to
sort of like justify how I came to
my conclusions. That part of it in,
in person conversations usually will
not lend itself to like screaming or
violence or whatever.
If that part is the focus.
I I completely agree with you on that.
Yeah. I think we'd be better off
if we did try to communicate with,
but when you're doing comedy
that goes out the window.
It does.
But Co even comedy aside,
I agree with the principal communicate
battle of ideas, a marketplace of ideas,
very,
very big ideas we all want to hear about
and what are the best ideas and let's
rank the ideas.
There are people whose views
are so extreme that you
can't really bring them to
the table as reasonable
negotiating partners for
figuring something out. Right?
Like Richard Spencer. Oh sure.
Or, or even, I mean, okay.
Imagine Farah Khan, uh, Louis Farrakhan
who I've spoken out about, uh, many times.
Imagine that we want to figure
out what the tax rate should be.
Something that politicians
have to do all the time.
If you have a group of people who
believe that we need a 25% flat tax and a
group of people who want,
you know,
like an escalating progressive tax
that gets as high as 70% on income,
over 10 million, whatever,
right? Like Philadel all,
then all those people are going
to be able to have a conversation.
If someone comes in who says any taxes
that the government collects are a form
of slavery,
how do you integrate that into the
conversation about how to set tax rates?
Hmm.
You can't, right? Yeah. So
all of this stuff, you know,
there's this new movement now,
which I think is great about long
form conversations going in depth,
figuring out what our disagreements
are like. I'm for all of it.
I'm absolutely for all of it. I think you
do it. I do it, I do it, and I'm sure,
okay.
But where I do think that there's like
a lack of of pragmatic reality to it is
some people's ideas are so extreme
that they can't in any sensible way,
be incorporated into an actual good
faith discussion of how society should be
organized.
That is the,
the problem with having
conversations and scale, right?
And that's the problem with Twitter and
with youtube that you're dealing with
millions and millions and
millions of human beings.
And when you have that
broad spectrum of humans,
you're going to have people
on the far ends of both sides.
And at a certain point they're a decision.
Has to be made about who actually gets
to participate in the decision making
conversations,
right?
It's great for everybody to have
a voice on taxation on Twitter.
But imagine if there was a
significant portion of the,
of our elected officials who
straight up think taxes are slavery.
Like I just don't know how that becomes
integrated into a decision about tax
policy.
Right?
Um,
I think the argument would be that bad
ideas should be combated with good ideas,
not with silencing someone.
And that when you do silence someone,
you just sort of create this blockade
where the idea of builds up behind it and
then the opposition to your perspective
builds up and then people start picking
teams and picking sides.
And,
and I honestly think that that's something
that's going to be going on right now
with the sole Crowder Crowder,
vox thing.
I think people are going to pick
sides and they fucking love it.
People love a good to get into.
There's
a lot of people in the cubicles right now
that are weighing in and firing up and
there's people that want to dock him
again and these people want to infiltrate
as Facebook and it's Twitter. That's what
people do. And you're dealing with milk.
I mean the car, what does
the crowd or have 3.5, 3.8
million, something like that.
I mean,
I think what you have to also remember
is it's not just the reactions that are,
uh, sort of like tailored to continue
the escalation. I mean, in the end,
maybe Crowder personally in his personal
life does refer to people he perceives
to be gay or who are gay as
queers. I don't know. I don't,
or he uses the word fags. I have no
idea. Well, he didn't use that word.
The t shirt. It has the asterisk I get,
it's a goof. It's actually as a fig.
It doesn't have an asterisk.
The okay. Or an ae is a fig.
Okay. For figs. It's the
idea. It's an, I got it. Okay.
It's a goofy joke. Fair. My point
is, um, I don't know, you know,
any sensible person who lives in the
west and has access to media like Steven
Crowder or whoever knows that the use of
that language has a very specific path,
that and set of reactions that it's
going to trigger you. Specifically the,
that shirt,
the shirt and honoring to Carlos
Mazda as a young queer Mexican or,
or whatever the phrase is.
That's a w one w the queer one is a weird
one because it's what it's with Lbgtq.
Like what is like,
here's a good one, right?
National Association for the advancement
of colored people. Okay. Naacp.
You can't call people colored people.
Sure.
But that organization was
named a long time ago. It's,
it's more acronyms than anything else
at this point, Sam. But it's not right.
You both,
we both know what the acronym with the
individual letters or words in that
acronym are.
I think the word queer
is not a derogatory word,
but it is, or it cannot be,
depending on how it's, Yo,
you fucking queer. Yeah, sure.
I mean, listen, it's the same way with
Jew. Right, right, right, right, right.
I'm in a family thing and it's
a bunch of Jews or whatever.
That's a word that can be used in
a way that if someone shows up,
if Richard Spencer shows up or one of
his followers and goes to a bar Mitzvah
and talks about this room full of Jews,
the word is the same root word less.
We're talking about two very
different things. That's a good point.
But should he be allowed to say this
room full of Jews allowed? I mean,
it's not illegal. No, it's not illegal.
He wasn't allowed. He is allowed,
but where does it like this room full
of w where does it get toxic? Well,
if Richard Spencer shows up at a,
at a bar Mitzvah and yells about
this room full of Jews, I think, uh,
it's gotten toxic.
Yeah.
That's a good subject to break this
stalemate of this subject, not steal me,
but just sort of end this antisemitism,
right.
Seems to be ridiculously on the
rise and that, that's stunning to
me. That shocked me when I
lie because of the Internet,
the Internet sort of exposed antisemitism
that I didn't necessarily know existed.
I see at the levels that existed at,
I knew there was antisemites,
but I didn't even know there
were so brazen in over.
Well, they've gotten brazen
since January of 2017. Oh,
okay.
I don't know that Donald
Trump has created antisemites.
In fact, he probably hasn't, well his
son in law's choose son-in-laws Jewish,
his daughter converted to Judaism,
etc. Uh,
but I think that Richard Spencer told me,
we know that Trump is not literally a
white nationalist who is going to talk
about let's take control
back from the Jews.
But we see him as the closest
thing to what we would like.
He talks about people from Mexico,
he talks about shithole
countries, et cetera. Um,
so it's just emboldened the movement.
It doesn't necessarily create
people from Mexico and should hold
countries that doesn't necessarily really
equate with Israel.
No. Well, antisemitism in Israel also
are two totally separate thing. I mean,
think it's just a,
you could be against the current Israeli
administration as I am like Benjamin
Netanyahu and still call out antisemitism
against Jews in the short states,
for example, or whatever. I see
what you're saying. It doesn't,
one is not directly linked to the other,
but if you're a group that already has
these views and then you see a guy who
opens his campaign talking about, um,
they're sending rapists and criminals,
but some I'm sure are good people and
I don't want people coming here from
shithole countries. What about Norwegians?
Whatever. Right. It's a signal.
It's a signal.
And I've spoken to former KKK people,
some of whom are really interesting people
to talk to and they know exactly why
it's appealing because they see the
signals and the vocabulary and the dog
whistling. So I think it's just
brought it out into the forefront.
I don't know that new antisemitism
has necessarily been generated,
although it being in the
forefront probably does
start to get some people kind
of curious like, oh, maybe
all the problems are because
of the Jews. I don't know.
Mm.
It's just a,
I guess they find groups of like minded
folks and they join along. Right?
Is that the antisemites? Yeah. The,
they find them online and then you can
stumble into it where you ordinarily
wouldn't be around people that
are having those discussions
that can happen.
And a lot of the people that I've talked
to that got into those beliefs and then
out of them said that they got
in usually on a community level,
there was something about the community
that was appealing to like gangs, gangs,
or in the case of KKK and white
supremacy, people that, um,
had a bad home situation and they
found a group that would accept them.
Like partially they would accept them
because they were white. Right. Um,
and then they got pulled into
the beliefs and eventually they,
they sort of got out of them.
Yeah.
It's just a,
so you think the rise of in
2017 there's more antisemitism,
or do you think it's more or for overt,
I believe it's moreover because Trump was
the president. Yeah. Hmm. And you know,
groups that track these,
uh, incidents like the Anti
Defamation League and others,
they have the data and
there have been increases.
Hmm. Yeah. It's, it's
stunning to me. You know, you,
you see it online so many different places
now and I just don't remember seeing
it before or not like that.
Not that's you'd run into it.
So often are people calling
people design is shills.
Yeah. I mean that's an important
thing to talk about. I mean,
people call me that all the
time. Mm. And, um, you know,
I feel like that is an
issue where I try to speak,
I mean she'll to me suggests
that you're saying one thing,
but with some kind of other agenda
that you're trying to push in some way.
In other words,
you are,
you are being in some way deceptive about
your actual intentions in what you say.
So I think when people
call me a Zionist shill,
what they mean is I'm talking about one
thing with the secret goal or below the
surface goal of actually promoting
some action by the state of Israel.
I think that's the idea of a shill.
Um, but you know, I mean, I, I,
I'm opposed to the current
prime minister in Israel. Uh,
I've made clear that isn't in
trouble right now. Uh, yeah.
I mean he's been in tentative
trouble for a long time.
His wife is in trouble as well,
I believe. Um, but that, I mean,
the problem is, and I know that there
are people on the left and right,
that when I say this will,
I'm gonna,
I mean I'm going to get crushed
from what I'm about to say.
Sometimes when someone says Zionist Shill,
it's related to your view on the
Israeli Palestinian conflict.
Sometimes when someone's has sinus shell,
it's covered for just wanting to
insult someone for being Jewish or for
antisemitism. You gotta look
at every instance one by one.
Yeah. And sometimes people just
like saying things too. Yeah. Yeah.
It's a popular thing to say, especially
if they find out that you're Jewish.
Absolutely. It's like a thing. Yeah.
It's a thing to say it's a little
weapon to use. It absolutely is.
Do you find,
this is sort of an abstract question,
but overall like doing this show and,
uh,
and having this increased ever
increased exposure, do you,
do you enjoy it?
Are you,
are you weirded out by the
interactions with all the people?
Do you feel pressure by all
the comments and the, the,
do you feel like a little bit of anxiety
from all the social media aspect of it?
I, I do. Um, so I,
I enjoy the idea that people are listening
to my ideas and either agreeing or
disagreeing,
but they're considering them and then
integrating it into how they figure out
what they think about the world
around them. That's awesome.
I do get weirded out
by sort of like safety,
security stuff that sometimes comes up,
which I try not to even like put too
much attention on because I feel like it
just feeds,
it gives people ideas and um,
people who, you know,
come up to me and I mean,
I'm more curious to actually hear
your thoughts about this. Uh,
come up to me and you know,
they may not necessarily see the world
the way I see it and I'm unsure sort of
like what are their intentions
type of thing. I mean, I,
it gives me anxiety and it gives people
that are close to me. Anxiety for sure.
Yeah, because your profiles, just if you
keep doing this, you're very good at it.
Thank you. You're going to continue
to get more and more popular.
Yeah. And I mean I guess it's a double
edged sword. I mean, I don't know.
Like when when you do a
comedy show afterwards,
is it kind of like a free for all where
people can come up and chat with you
sometimes. Yeah. Yeah. And do you
get skiddish? No. You don't know.
Most people are nice. I agree.
The vast majority of people
are nice. I agree. They,
they come to see you.
They're there.
They're usually fans and they just
want to take pictures of say what's up.
Yeah. I guess it's a little different when
what you do is like overtly political.
Yes. Versus other areas. Like if you're
an actor, comedian doing the right things,
race, car driver. Yeah.
Right. You are in a much more
conflict driven profession. Yeah.
In a sense. Yeah. I mean I,
I have political people on
like you, but um, you know,
I'm not entirely engaged in
politics like you guys are,
right? Yeah. I don't know. I mean,
I do worry that no matter what
happens in the next few elections,
I don't know how we reverse the,
uh,
radicalization polarization effects of
the social media echo chambers that we've
been talking about. And I only
see that as further. I mean,
we could still accomplish good
things while that's going on.
Like I think if we elect the right people,
maybe we can get good things done.
But in parallel,
there is this like hyper radicalized,
polarized narrative that's going on.
And I don't see any way that
that's going to turn around.
I wonder myself. I do.
I, and, and I'm very,
very confused by it because I don't see
any longterm solution for this other
than some radical change in the way
human beings communicate with each other.
And now that I've contemplated
that and hypothesized,
theorized and I really think that if what
has changed the way we communicate as
technology and this,
um,
the immersive immersive aspect
of social media technology,
the fact that we carry these devices
with us all the time that allow us to
communicate and allowed us to read
other people's communications and,
or watch or the people's communications.
And I have a concern that this
is going to escalate with each x,
each expansion and each innovation
in terms of like what I,
and I don't know what it would be
because no one saw the internet coming.
If you go back 30 years ago,
no one ever thought anything was going
to be anything like it is now. Well,
Al Gore did. Ha, I bet
he did. Um, but if you,
but if you go 30 years from now, I mean,
what are we really looking at? What, what,
what, what, what is this world going to
be? I don't think anybody has an idea.
I think we have no idea. And I think it's
going to be, if you look at the trend,
the trend is not towards calming
people down and giving people space and
allowing people to meditate more and know
that the trend is to get more and more
immersed.
Right?
The trend is for us to get closer and
closer to each other to remove boundaries,
room boundaries for information
and ideas and even in longterm,
um, contemplations of this, I've
often thought that everything right,
all of our communication is basically
ones and Zeros. It's all information.
It's all words and thoughts and
videos and now you're getting into
cryptocurrency now. Crypto currencies,
essentially ones and Zeros.
It's all digital.
Everything is digital and the bottlenecks,
if any bottlenecks are there at all.
The bottlenecks are slowly but
surely getting removed. This, the,
the Bot,
the blockades and the walls.
I think we're going to
probably experienced some
sort of a level of immersive
technology in our lifetimes that's
going to change the way human beings
communicate period. And that we're going
to look back at this time like, Huh,
I remember when we thought that like
social media arguments where like the big
deal. Yeah. Yeah.
I um,
I was a recent,
I used to have more of like a techno
Utopian view and it started to sort of
change partially because of some of
the Psi Phi I read [inaudible] and
everything.
But most recently,
so like 15 years ago I read the Richard
Came Oregon book altered carbon.
Uh, and at the time I was like,
this has to be made into something.
That's the one that's on Netflix now.
And then like a year ago,
Joel Kinnaman was in the
series and it was just awesome.
And the series is quite good
as yours is quite good. Yeah.
And I really liked Joel Kinnaman and
I, you know, Richard came Morgan,
I interviewed who wrote
the book years ago,
but that genre started to move me away
from techno utopianism and technology's
just going to solve so many problems
because it also is going to create new
problems that we don't even
yet know about. So as an
example, I went all the back,
all the way back to the beginning when
humans went from hunter gatherers and
figured out we can domesticate some crops,
we can start agriculture and
settle and be in one place.
That was the acceleration of what
we know of as wealth ownership.
What it was like the start,
right. So much of what we had,
I mean agriculture allowed people to
be able to live and do stuff other than
find food which developed
specialists who created technology,
which created armies like it all
came from agriculture in that way,
but tons of bad stuff came
from it as well. Right.
The beginning of the concept of a
sedentary lifestyle came from agriculture
diseases that we got from animals and
then that we brought other places and they
killed tons of people. So I've kind of
adopted that view to technology, which is,
yeah,
all
the cool stuff we can imagine and
improvements. I'm sure we'll be there,
but problems we aren't even aware of
yet are also going to be there. Yeah,
I agree with you 100% that's what I meant
by looking back at this social media
problem. I think we're going to have a
far more invasive problem. I think the,
I think we're going to probably have
some sort of a wearable thing that allows
us to communicate through thoughts.
Sure. Well thoughts would be a next step,
but at minimum, I mean replacing, you
don't need the screen on your phone.
You have contacts that are connected
to something and everything is just
displayed. I mean
there'll be steps, Jamie,
whatever happened with that Microsoft
thing that we were looking at.
Remember when they had like the little
mouse that was dancing in your hand or
the elephant that was
dancing in your hand?
That is a micro segmented. Yes.
That wasn't available. It wasn't.
My Microsoft has hollow Lens
and they're on a Hololens to,
but they've moved more towards like a,
uh,
commercial applications for it as
opposed to like consumer availability.
There are consumer availability,
ar things coming out right now.
They're what apple just showed up there.
A WWDC event this month or
actually on Monday is really cool.
[inaudible] it's still just like
watching a, through that phone though.
They're not,
I don't think anyone's made the device
like a glasses type ar thing yet because
the uh, field of view isn't right
to haven't mastered that either.
A projecting light into your eye,
which is what magic leap does,
are projecting onto the glass
that you're then looking at,
which is where I think hollow Lens and
the other thing does that sort of figured
it out yet. Beta Max versus VHS race
to see who figures things. So yeah,
but like the oculus quest,
which is different just also just came
out is really cool and there's so close,
so much closer.
There could be within a year or two or
something good come out at the end of
this year that hasn't been announced.
We're very close.
Question is like how much is that
going to affect daily life, right.
With augmented reality.
Yeah.
The other one that relates to that also
is right now you at least can put your
phone away.
That's what happens when the line between
the technology and the body is a bit
about it. Um, I'm very concerned.
I really am. I'm just a,
I think we're giving up
agency to something that has
no feelings for us at all.
Well, there's no, I mean I think
the problems people have, uh,
in practice often are
different than the ones.
I mean there's no transparency with a
lot of the companies that are developing
these technologies and setting up
the algorithms and whatever. Um,
there's really no transparency
about what it is that's going on,
what the end goals are, what the broader
effects on society are going to be. Um,
I know you've had Jonathan Heit
on who was talked a lot about the
disproportionate effect of
social media on suicidality,
particularly in young
girls, relative to boys. Um,
it's been years now that this stuff
has been around and we're now kind of
figuring that out.
So it's inevitably we're behind always
and figuring out what the effects are
because you need time to measure it and
that as things advance more and more
quickly,
whatever damage
is potentially going to be
done will happen even faster.
Yes. Yeah. That's what the concern is,
that we are always behind and that it's
sneaking into our lives before we have
any idea of how dangerous it is.
Sure. I mean, this happened
with, you know, the food,
the canned and processed food revolution
of the fifties and sixties it was
slower,
but it was the same type of thing where
all of these advancements and being able
to make food last longer via
how it was processed and stored.
It all sounded awesome at a time
when food would just go bad.
Then we started learning about all
that things that come with it. Exactly.
Yeah. Uh, anything more for rabbit up?
I think that's it. Oh, I w so two
things I wanted to mention. One,
when I announced that I was
going to be on the show,
companies started contacting me saying,
we will give you money if you work hour,
a name our product into the conversation.
What's the product?
I'm not going to say, but I do want to
talk about car insurance briefly. Um,
have you heard that that's
happened to other guests?
No. You haven't? Interesting. That's
interesting. Yeah. Wow. That's a weird,
sneaky thing. Yeah. And no one's ever
paid me to do that. No one's paid you.
No, no, no one's ever paid
me to uh, to have an like a,
a conversation on a podcast. Oh. Um,
but one company did want to advertise
and they wanted their CEO to come on the
podcast and discuss their
product and I was like,
give me like an infomercial. I
was like, no. And they were like,
well you've talked about people before
that have had products before. I go, yeah.
Because I liked their product and I
think what they're doing is cool. Right.
I is zero financial investment
in their product. Right.
Only did it because I like it.
Sure. Well, I mean, peep,
my audience knows that we do sponsored
stuff like adding whatever I disclose it.
I'm clear and my approaches,
I'm super upfront with my audience,
which is listen me to only like half
a percent of you are paying for a
membership.
The memberships are six bucks a month.
I know like 80% of you can afford it.
Only like half a percent are doing it.
That's fine.
I'm going to keep doing the show,
but I'm going to put some sponsored
content up. You don't have to watch it.
I'm in a market as such period.
And I feel like for the most part we have
kind of an understanding of how it all,
there's nothing wrong with it as long
as this products that you actually enjoy
and again, that you maintain
that transparency and honesty.
There's nothing wrong with that.
If I don't have that with the audience,
I don't have anything. Right. And, and I,
I've asked, been asked to compromise it.
You hadn't? Yeah, for sure. Yeah. It's
just flick. It would be worth so much,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean there's this moral hazard sort
of situation that exists with insurance
where the people who don't really need
the insurance are the ones that the
insurance companies want to insure.
And the people that are more
likely to use the insurance,
the insurance companies are like,
we're going to have to charge you
six times as much type of thing.
It's easier to get the sponsorship money
from stuff that's less interesting or
less aligned or whatever.
And I don't know. I mean,
it's an ongoing battle.
I don't talk to any of our advertisers.
Like we have a team that handles
all of that and that is great. Um,
but they're,
you know,
there are still calls to make about
like what is on this side of the line,
what's on that side of the line. I
tried to make the right calls. No,
I think you're doing a great
job. I appreciate your show.
I appreciate your time.
Thanks for coming down here and tell
everybody where they can find you.
D pacman on Pa k man on,
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
I'm on. Where am I? I'm on Instagram at
David Dot. Pacman and uh, my website,
David pakman.com. Alright, thank you
David. My pleasure. Thanks for having me.
Great.